[Music]
n
nah
[Music]
oh
pap
[Music]
n
he
[Music]
he's down a piece he's down two pawns a
couple of checks Magus King is going to
dance easily out of them take my queen
and give me a new one please he's losing
now he walks right into the and they
know it they know it turn your boards
909 952 made a big my oh and the bar is
going up this is an absolute Gem of a
game Wesley saw has done it he's going
in for the attack but he's walked into
Checkmate black can play Rook takes
porn one move Checkmate two seconds oh
oh my God why an arm we
in It's the final day here at the 2024
Chess Masters the first leg of the
champion chest tour I'm Robert H
alongside me is Grandmaster David Howell
we will be providing all the coverage of
this clash between Aliva fua and Magnus
Carlson David we saw division 2 and
division 3 and yesterday vit kimer Alexi
Sano were victorious they entered the
day with two lives rather than their
opponents one do you think Magnus
Carlson will give us the same shot well
if yesterday was anything to go by then
it does look likely that Magnus Carlson
is a favorite whether we get to that
second m match is the first question
Robert but uh yesterday what a great
warmup that was today is the main course
will it be magnificent Magnus will it be
Allstar Alara either way it's going to
be a lot of fun to watch well I hope
everyone brought their appetite because
this is going to be the treat that we
all want to see we started with eight
players in division 1 but now we are
down to two illustrious names like Maxim
fasher grav Wesley so yand pomi they are
no longer in this field in fact Ali Raa
fuia he went through the entirety of the
losers bracket after being defeated in
his first match against Vladimir fedos
if you see here on screen he took down
Yap pami in an Armageddon before that he
beat Jose Martinez and Wesley so last
but certain not least was Dennis lazic
the 17-year-old sensation who shocked
people over the years but no longer can
it come as surprise when he beats the
likes of even Magnus Carlson but
speaking of Magnus he worked his way
through to the Grand Final unscathed in
terms of matches but David he did have
some blemishes on that record that's
right Magnus wasn't in Top Gear it felt
like Magnus was doing Magnus things of
course he's the big boss he always seems
to get the job done but not quite in top
form and now Magnus has had two days off
so uh Robert my question is whether
alaza who's a bit Fresher a bit sharper
having played a couple of days ago
whether he can get the job done now he's
on a roll he's got that momentum behind
him or whether Magnus will uh finally
show his best chess and uh just quash
the challenge of the young Pretender um
there's a lot to play for I've got to
say despite Magnus starting as the
favorite allera he's been so impressive
this whole event he has been and ala
fuja was handpicked by Magnus Carlson a
few years ago back when we still called
him the world champion he said I will
play the world championship title under
one condition if Aly Raa fui is my
Challenger that didn't happen David so
there always is added pressure a bigger
feel to this matchup between Magnus and
ala than you would think anyone else
yeah the world championship might not
have got this match but here at the CCT
Champions chestor We are treated to this
match and who knows Robert maybe
somewhere down the line if Magnus gets
Restless comes back uh to the Glasco
World Championship but uh yeah this
Young Generation Alara has been
spearheading them for a while now of
course so many prodes in their team
Alara he's around 20 now but um yeah he
is going to be hoping that he can
Dethrone Magnus in this match at least
in his home territory of the
CCT well if any of the last few matches
or any indication ala fua is ready for a
fight if you missed any of the previous
days well we've got you covered let's
relive the hyp together and here's that
video it's the fight to challenge Magnus
Carlson in the grand finals three
players in the arena only one will
survive Perfect Defense from fuja
continuing to keep the king and that was
what was that from y he gave away his
Rook there's still a chance he might
blunder it's still possible to go wrong
be toop players finally it's a draw Rob
did you see that he gave away his Rook
so a bit of humor between these two y
he's just checking he's just hoping now
but 36 37 seconds Al is forcing the
Queens off otherwise it's Checkmate is
this the end of the end's tournament it
is the end of the road for Yan well that
was given a question mark But Black's
response was bad because now the carpet
is rolled out for the white king I think
Dennis down the two seconds he knows
that this one is Ali razes for the take
I think he's just in time here fua to
hold the draw he has this under control
it is fua who progresses but Dennis
threw everything at this game he got so
close a lot of credit to him he's so
impressive at the youngster Magnus
Carson gets the match that he
wanted and we are down to two Ali Raza
fua he went through some tough hurdles
in y palomi and Dennis lazic a couple
days ago but they both of these players
they had at least one day off and in the
case of magus Carlson two full days of
vacation does that actually make players
lose their Steam certainly does from my
experience of uh kind of these big big
tournaments if you're in good form you
want to keep going uh if you have a day
off two days off in magnus's case as you
mentioned then it feels like a new
tournament it feels uh like you're
already Gathering some Rust so for
Magnus who he did mention in the
interview has been traveling uh to
Germany this past 24 hours it might not
be as smooth sailing as he would like of
course it takes two to tango two
energetic players to throw everything at
each other uh that's what we're hoping
for but who will start quicker in a
relatively short match the first match
at least of four games it's about that
fast start and uh Robert I don't know
about you but uh youth prevailed
yesterday do you think that's going to
happen today with
ala well yesterday youth had two lives
today ala is on his last life from the
start but let's just dive into the
numbers because while both these players
had days off and now it's going to be a
true fight and you see the history
between these two Magnus Carlson 13
years ala senior they have played a
number of times in Rapid you see Magnus
with 14 wins to seven for ala but that's
nothing to sneeze at David both these
players have a wealth of experience in
this top division but seven victories
over Magnus Carlson that's a lot for the
youngster yeah that's seven victories
more than most people achieve in their
lifetime and uh he needs to take
inspiration from that uh despite being
picked out by Magnus himself as a future
Challenger potentially Alara he
struggled in Bal chess over the board
it's very one-sided Magnus with the
upper hand um here we see them in the
Toronto finals where Magnus ended up
winning last season but um yeah Alara
he's got experience he has taken down
Magnus on occasion but putting it
together in one match potentially two
matches today it's going to be a big big
task and uh yeah Robert if Magnus
couldn't play as calmly as he did in the
pictures we're seeing in front of us
back in December then he's going to be
hard to
stop things have not been so calm in the
ches Masters for Magnus Carlson you see
win win win all he does is win no matter
what but Vladimir fedos of took Magnus
to Armageddon after flagging the world
number one in what should have been dra
territory and then F had a winning
opportunity it was tough to spot in
Armageddon and let's not forget Dennis
lazic he beat Magnus with the black
pieces so David we see Magnus he
continues to win the matches but it's
been a bit shaky yeah it has Magnus
admitted that himself as well in the
interview saying he's not quite at his
best um these later starts in the
afternoon his time um they haven't quite
been clicking for him of course it's the
sign of a true great a real athlete that
they're able to get the job done uh to
squeeze through and uh be victorious
even when they're not at their best but
he knows against a inform Aller he'll
need to be better today no more of those
one move blunders no more of those uh
kind of fig about the clock and losing
on time situations Magnus wants to be
perfect today as you said you cannot
afford to slip up against ala fuja we
know that he could punch up he is not
the most stable player sometimes he in
fact loses to low rated players that you
wouldn't expect and as you saw in this
Chess Masters he actually lost the first
match to fedos his play was quite strong
but in those final seconds against fedos
he was the one who faltered sent down to
the losers bracket and well it should be
called the losers bracket with Fu's in
it because he won every single match
down there and he has revived his event
making his way to the Grand Final by
beating Wesley Jose Jan and Dennis David
that is a real tough set of matches and
ala fer he proved that he was strong
enough yeah he loves chess and he's
pretty much played the maximum number of
games he could have done over this past
week and uh we love his style how
aggressive he is how uncompromising
always always playing the most ambitious
move that's why Magnus as a sign of
respect singled him out that's why
Magnus loves facing alera one of the
most popular players on the tour on the
scene and uh yeah of course a dangerous
opponent for anyone on his day Robert
you mentioned things can go wrong but
they can go very very right such a high
ceiling and uh yeah Magnus has suffered
on the end of that
before and when things look like a
virtual certainty Al Raza f is the type
of player who who can shake them up and
Magus Carlson entered the event with
huge winning chances of course he's the
favorite no matter the tournament that
he plays and his winning odds the win
probability still around 90% but a
curious note here David his win
probability went down while oliv razes
went up so what do you make of that I'm
no stats expert Math's expert Robert but
uh all I know is that alaza emerging
from uh that losers final instead of
Dennis lazovic this means it going to be
a tougher task a taller order for Magnus
Carson still huge favorite mainly due to
his high rating and the fact he has two
lives here uh in today's Grand Final but
uh yeah it's still room for Eric Magnus
at 90% yes everyone supporting him yes
everyone's expecting it but if he has
one of those off days if that man on the
camera who just disappeared uh can be a
bit of a magician bit of a Houdini and
bring his best chest then yeah Magnus
cannot relax too soon and aler is a fer
is on his last life Magnus Carlson has
two but we've seen the upset in the past
in the AI cup in the 2023 Champions
chest tour Maxim V grv did the
unthinkable The Impossible he beat
Magnus Carlson in consecutive matches of
David we know it can happen yeah it's
happened before and it was a fellow
Frenchman Vash gra all is a very good
friend of his maybe he would have been P
picking mv's brain how did you do it
what mindset was required and he would
have been examining those games between
mvl and Magnus where mvl struck back won
those two matches it was always crazy
games every single one of them uh he
really tested Magnus confused Magnus and
uh when lightning happens once you know
that it can strike again so there is
hope for
Ana there certainly is and when there's
a lot at stake the pressure sometimes
hits you you got to keep your nerves and
there is quite a lot up for grabs here
are our ches Master standings presented
by wealth management partner Julius bear
you see two blanks on screen here in
division 1 that's because we don't know
who is going to be slotted in as the
champion of this first event of the 2024
season but David a lot of prize money
has already been given out you see
Dennis lck taking home a cool
$15,000 and those 60 tour points will
Magnus rank Supreme once more gain the
30k or will Ali Raza fuja upset him to
take home that $110,000 prize difference
David so much money so many tour points
and an automatic spot to the Champions
chess tour on line that's right I think
for these two players that's the bigger
prize the winner of this event qualifies
straight through to the tour finals at
the end of the season Magnus Carlson of
course he wants to win he's such a
perfectionist um the money will be
inspiration the prize will be
inspiration but he just wants to win
chess games and alaza I think for him
the biggest motivation is taking down
his rival to show he can do it what a
statement that would be Robert just
before the candidates matches in a
couple of months if ala can take down
Mighty
Magnus that would be a huge statement
from the Iranian French player he now
plays under the French flag of course he
grew up in Iran and you see Magnus
Carlson and Aliva fuia they're getting
set and David I thought before that
Magnus was setting the room temperature
of the chess it's going to be heated no
matter what there's nothing you can do
when you play against ala F you cannot
have a quiet match it's just that is
something that is impossible yeah I've
never seen it be boring between these
two and uh often Magnus really loves
thrives on that challenge he knows
there'll be throwing everything at each
other here and uh Magnus he's been
traveling this is a new location
throughout the chessable Masters we've
seen him play from elsewhere will he be
able to adapt will he be able to adjust
like you said he was fiddling with some
settings there uh no matter what it was
and soon that heated battle will
commence on the
chessboard and we know that both of
these two are about to be in the
freestyle goat challenge the question
for Magnus Carlson is can he freestyle
today because when you face off against
alera fuja you don't know what to expect
when is he just going to play a quiet
opening and when is he going to lash out
and from fuja we saw him in a classical
event the Tod of Steel Chess Masters he
beat Yan pomi he beat world champion
ding L Ren but he also lost to two of
the lower rated players in the field to
very strong Grand Masters in their own
right in Alexander donchenko and Jan Jun
so David it's that topsy tury style he
kind of takes us on a roller coaster
ride but against Magnus Carlson you
can't have those downward slopes it has
to be all uphill exactly you cannot
throw out one or two bad moves here or
there you will be punished and uh I
think that's why we love him ala fuja
because it's up down uh he can throw out
a brilliant sacrifice and amazing mating
sequence but also the occasional
overoptimistic uh blunder but uh as you
say Robert no room for error today he
needs to get through the match he'll be
taking it move by move game by game but
this first best of four match is
essential I was just thinking though
Robert they're probably playing a few
hotel rooms away from each other just
down the corridor uh out there in
Germany right now yeah Fabiano Carana
laavan rodian might be in between them
maybe Vincent kimer so if you hear some
cuss words screamed out I'm sure some
super grandmas will be there to pick up
that sound David we're just about set
here yeah we're good to go and the moves
surely will begin L Magnus what are we
expecting from the opening will he with
white take a solid approach just ease
his way into the match he plays Porto G3
Robert not his traditional E4 not
occupying the center a frown for Magnus
he's uh snacking up or drinking
something but G3 is that a
surprise it's certainly a surprise but
when Magnus Carlson is playing you just
can't expect anything and I know that
sounds cliche but it's true the best
players in the world they can play any
opening Under the Sun they can throw
their Rook pawns forward on the first
move which is inadvisable so don't do it
yourselves don't try this at home but
Magnus Carlson has won title Tuesdays
playing his Rook pawns on the first turn
and David we have no Pawn tension yet
and finally we do the pawn comes up to
C4 this is familiar territory it
resembles a Catalin opening mixed with
the grunfeld that's right it's a real
hybrid here and uh it looks like a
belated Queen's Gambit this Pawn can
simply be captured the pawn that's just
landed on C4 for white but it will be
regained in short order White Queen can
come out or the White Knight on B1 can
come out and uh snap off that pawn so uh
fuia here deciding to go for the solid
path the solid option just sets up a uh
a kind of Pawn Center there with black
now it's a mix M kind of a mishmash RIT
between the grunfeld and the slav
defense and finally as Pawn sacrifice
for Magnus he doesn't care he doesn't
even tried to regain the pawn just
occupies the center instead he has used
this in the past with success uh what do
you make of this I thought he would ease
his way in but he's already kind of uh
going for a really controversial idea
here with white controversial is a good
way of putting it I think that fua
should be happy because he didn't
actually have to bring the fight to
Magnus Magnus allowed this position to
be reached and what we have to note is
that white is a pawn down black has
successfully defended the extra Pawn the
Queen's Gambit Pawn so to speak and
white is occupying the center look at
this latest move D5 this Rook on D1 is
behind the pawn now it's been captured
David I love positions like this and ala
if he's not careful he could be in
trouble but he's ignoring and
sacrificing his Knight what a position
we have what a position and it is a
familiar position I do believe Magnus
has uh employed this before um in the
Champions chess tour actually or at
least a very similar idea he's a piece
to the good but three pawns for black
it's a matter of timing if black can
motor those pawns forward the Ed C pawns
if they start running then they will
simply Steamroller The White position
but for now a piece is a piece white has
an extra Bishop so who will be able to
utilize their strengths here uh for
white the Ace of sleeve is the bishop
potentially the bishop on G2 for black
it is that mass of Pawns that horde of
Pawns and Robert this is guaranteed to
be a fight both players clearly well
prepared by the uh kind of speed with
which they've been playing thank you for
connecting for there I love that I love
that pawn chain for black um this one
wow we couldn't have hoped for a more
exciting beginning to this game no it's
a clear imbalance the extra Bishop for
white on G2 those four pawns that we
just highlighted for black and so let's
try to talk about the outline of this
position that white is up a bishop a
long range piece that sounds really good
but black has this fort of Pawns that
that Bishop's not getting any Active
Space so what white needs to do is sort
of chisel open some lines for the pieces
there is direct direct access to a
square like C6 maybe this A5 Pawn will
be targeted later and look at all the r
say well what A5 Pawn I'm going to keep
rushing those pawns off the board David
we could see a pass Pawn in the very
near future yeah robt we could see one
pass Pawn maybe two pass pawns maybe
even three pass pawns for black
depending on how white reacts right now
that is the definition of ambitious Pawn
to A4 he's not even trying to prepare
things build up normally in chess uh it
is the ultimate war war game after all
you need to just uh kind of uh kind of
organize your army before lashing out
before going in and uh moving in for the
kill onto your opponent's terrain but
right now he's just said go and pawn A4
it looks really loose I've got to say
this last move for black but if white
cannot win those pawns if white cannot
prevent the creation of pass pawns then
Magnus will start sweating and you see
him on the camera doesn't look entirely
comfortable yet he's a minute down on
the clock this is just sparkling
preparation from uh from black here from
Ala f full credit to him like you said
Magnus is taking the fight to him but
he's not backing down at all he's taking
significant risks most players myself
included prefer to play solid with the
black pieces especially against these
top ground Masters minimal risk but who
cares if you're ala fua and uh so many
easy moves Queen to B6 now looks like
the best way to get out of the hit and I
guess Robert Magnus is trying to trade
off pawns seek Some solid there he has
to I just don't think you're can allow
these black pawns to stay anymore he so
he grabs uh this B4 Pawn which was loose
only because Aliva pushed the pawn to A4
so this takes preparation this takes
deep understanding of a position to give
up a pawn that is slightly closer to the
center and just push your Rook Pawn
forward but at this stage I think for
Magnus it's about solidifying Bishop to
D2 I like that choice however the B2
Pawn will be in danger down the line if
this Knight could successfully get to E4
black would be in business however that
Knight will be chopped off right away
and that also hurts Black's Pawn
structure so for now black can't just go
full steam ahead can't press all the
pieces forward uh this is a really
difficult position to decipher David I
think that I would rather have the black
side but I feel like I'm going to regret
those words you're right Robert it is
one of those positions I think we'll be
changing our assessment our evaluation
move by move because it is wild the game
has been super high quality up to this
point really high accuracy because it's
may need been preparation but um as the
feature chat says that the pawns are
coming the mistakes will likely come
later down the line because it is a bit
irrational this position it's very rare
to find yourself with this material
imbalance with such strong pawns for
either side and um okay ala for the
first real time in this game having a
longer think what do you feel is going
through his mind Robert what uh is he
aiming for next or is he just enjoying
this possession he told us he takes a
step back with his Knight to take two
steps forward that Knight can jump into
C5 and then there are juicy squares like
D3 and B3 for that piece but look at
Magnus he has an extra minor piece a
piece is worth three points in value
versus those three pawns and so he's
trying to get rid of this bishop in
front of the black king will we see
Alpha Magnus H4 H5 that looks feasible
to me at the moment and this Knight on
B4 David it's kind of like an outposted
Knight a pawn can't kick it away so if
black ever takes on C3 and the pawn
takes back you feel like you have a
well- defended piece however you are
allowing an outside pass Pawn which
could be scary every single turn has
some pretty major consequences yeah huge
consequences and uh therefore
significant decisions here and uh I mean
Magnus rightly spending time you don't
want to trade on the opponent's terms uh
you made a really good strategic point
there Robert Black's pawns are pretty
much all on light squares therefore the
dark Square Bishop is the uh commander
of that color complex has to be traded
off but you don't want to rush uh the
White Knight would feel really
uncomfortable without its bodyguard its
protector on C3 so I love your move Pawn
to H4 other moves that come to mind
would be maybe Rook to A3 just in case
you don't want to allow that black a
pawn to push Queen to E3 just
controlling those dark squares fighting
for ter territory um yeah so tense so
many decisions so many tempting
candidate moves here um but Magnus yeah
do you think the clock's going to play a
big role in this one it's relatively
simplified lots of exchanges already
Robert but super complicated
I think it's difficult for white to come
up with a plan and that's why Magnus is
sitting and thinking here you can make
any of the moves that David mentioned
and here he goes Alpha Magnus style
pressing the pawn forward and the queen
for black is divorced from the King and
David you've mentioned this so many
times and it's a very good point that if
black finds his King under some danger
he won't be able to withstand some of
this pressure for instance if you play
H5 white immediately strikes with G4 and
you're just trying to break open the
side of the board where both Kings sit
and White's Queen will enter Black's
Queen is far away yeah I sometimes feel
like I'm a broken record just repeating
the phrase but it keeps happening Robert
this entire division one of the Chester
bow Masters so many times players have
actually been directly checkmated but
every time it's because their Queen's on
the wrong flank on the wrong side of the
board and I'm looking at the black queen
right now it's not too happy it is uh
somewhat stifled by the White Knight
alone and um we said no obvious moves
for so at least nothing stood out but he
clearly has plans with this last move
Paul to H4 really inspired I love that
phrase I'm going to steal it Alpha
Magnus and will alpha ala now be able to
do something with his a PA potentially
um sun no obvious moves for black either
suddenly a bit of a dead end for the
pawn chain and perhaps that means that
Magnus has the upper hand here because
these Rooks they're connected for black
but where are you really going to move
them they're all not finding open files
and the only open file is is the B file
and this one little Knight here will
stop a queen and a rook because the
bishop defends it or a pawn will replace
the bishop to keep that Knight safe and
sound so in comes the Black Knight David
I think we can see a future plan for
black to March those pass pawns forward
the question becomes do you blockade
this a pawn with your rook and then say
I know my Rook is passive but at least
your Pawn isn't getting anywhere or do
you try to keep your Rooks connected
some more playing down the line I would
be too afraid I'm just going to be
honest with you I'd be too afraid to
move my rook and see this pass become
unopposed I totally agree and okay
Magnus didn't want to move his Rook at
all he didn't want to save it he takes a
bishop instead now White's Knight is
hanging and the rook in the corner is
hanging so he needs to justify um this
double attack he needs to get out of it
somehow with gain of tempo ala I think
the threat of PA to D4 there was just
too strong so Magnus reacts concretely
and uh this is the CCT the Champions
chest T Robert now you have to look for
CCT check checks captures and threats um
so I'm looking at Knight takes D5 I'm
looking at the check with Queen to E5 uh
what do you think is going through
magnus's mind it's a bit surprising to
me that he would take on G7 and then
think but it's a very good point from
you that white can't do nothing your
Rook is under attack so if you um move
your Rook away you drop your knight on
B4 if you move your knight you lose the
rook and remember that black already has
three pawns for a bishop so black would
actually be the one for a choice in the
event of a knight Retreat so instead of
retreating go going forward getting
aggressive giving back some of your
extra material that's an important
lesson that many in our audience should
learn that sometimes when you are ahead
you should think about changing the
imbalance and here Knight takes D5 is
one way to do it just to take back with
your Rook next and get some activity but
David I'm not entirely sure I'm buying
it and I'm not sure Magnus is buying it
either because he's slowed down he's
slowed down and it's getting dramatic 4
minutes sounds like a lot it is a lot in
simplified positions but this is still
crazy it's really Chao IC and White's
Knight or the rook in the corner one of
them is going to drop um that's why I
was suggesting Knight takes D5 Robert I
just felt like the Knight is going to
fall you might as well sell it for the
highest price but you're right I mean
black is going to be a porn up in those
ensuing positions black has this wall of
porn still he delivers a check first
Magnus and now the question is okay I
was going to ask the question the blue
arrow the allseeing Oracle suggests Pawn
to F6 breaking the pawn chain breaking
that beautiful light squared structure
of Pawns giving up E6 but gaining time
in the process how easy do you feel this
is Robert apparently the best move but
black could also be justified pushing
his King back to safety well ala he
answers before I can I think this made
perfect sense because if the black king
had moved back a turn to go white would
have had a free hand at an attack so at
least this forces the issue the queen
was under attack it had to move it
captures the pawn on E6 and now for
Alara he can take this Knight over here
on B4 but the point from Magnus is he
wants to take on D5 and go right after
this exposed King on the seventh rank so
we could see a material balance where
white could be down a rook but the
checking attacked it can be immensely
powerful this is anybody's game at this
point and alza he does take that Knight
that Knight could have saved itself had
it not been captured so the matal
currently sits at two extra pawns for
black D5 is loose The Rook on A1 is
hanging the King on G7 is under attack
this is Carlson f
this is the type of Chess that we love
to see between these two yeah fuja
playing with fire and Rook Sacrifice
from Magnus Carson you call it it's on
the board a double exclamation mark it's
a significant sacrifice now if the Black
Knight does take that white rook in the
corner it's so far offside the black
queen and king still divorced it feels
like this Checkmate Robert I think at
the very minimum after a check white
could also take that black rook in the
corner with that assassin that uh White
Bishop on G2 which has been lurking the
entire game and even if there's no
knockout blow you might be able to win
some material back deflect Black's Army
this has been really well calculated by
Magnus and Alla he leans back scratches
his head I think he might have
underestimated this I think suddenly he
realizes there's huge trouble around
that black king yes the evaluation bar
is still Level but he's the one walking
the tight route now Robert if we can
quickly bring up an analysis for it's
instructed to show what happens if this
Rook on A1 is captured I do not think
that ala is that brave and sometimes
bravery costs so Knight takes A1 you're
going to see the evaluation bar change
and there it goes because Rook D7 check
the black king can run forward but that
walks into other check you don't want
your king So out in the open you'd
rather Retreat to the corner but once
this happens David's eyes are good he
wears glasses for a reason Bishop takes
rook and The Rook cannot capture this
bishop this looks like would be good for
black but unfortunately for you you get
checkm directly Queen takes Pawn check
the king moves over and the queen slides
in front of the king with mate thanks to
a Rook on the seventh rank so David this
is a rook sacrifice but it's a rook that
we've just shown cannot be grabbed and
that's why Rook A7 protecting the king
is a smart try but here comes that
second Rook David I feel like Magnus
he's feeling it right now he's
sacrificed a pawn overall but in comes a
rook on the seventh rank seventh heaven
but only for the player with the white
pieces yeah and you have to be so
careful here fua we see another blue
arrow pop up so Rook to F7 the only
saving move here for black the only way
to keep the game going you have to
Simply curl up into a ball shut up shop
and try to survive this Onslaught you
need to defend your own Rook again save
the seventh rank protect it and I think
you need to guard the F6 Pawn uh
simultaneously Robert of course he finds
the best move the only defense and he
forces a trade of Rooks that will come
with a sigh of relief uh huge huge move
there found by fua he's defending well
and he's a pornup still so if he
survives this Onslaught it's not going
to be easy then he can look to the
future with confidence I was going to
say which way to recapture he takes back
with a rook and now Magnus either he has
to retreat or he trades off a second
pair of Rooks Queen and Bishop versus
queen and Knight often favor the queen
and Knight when they combine but they're
still on the wrong flank on the wrong
side of the board who do you feels
playing for a win Robert well look at
that exclamation point for King out into
the open King H6 the black king would
have been all alone in the corner and
this move Bishop D5 would have actually
been more harmful had the king been back
on h8 so who do I favor here
I I favor having a safe King the white
king is not in danger but perhaps black
can bring this queen down follow it up
with a knight to D2 and then maybe the
the white king Isn't So safe after all
because it needs to stay attached to
this Pawn this lonely little Pawn on F2
so I believe that Knight D2 should be
played here and in fact only move for
Ali Raza and David before we continue
going x no can we just shout out the
players for their 99 plus% accuracy in a
position that has been this SHP sharp
the whole way through wow we talked
about who would start faster who would
bring their aame they both have in this
final early days and your move on the
board black is threatening some nasty
checks nasty mating ideas Queen to F1
check winning the F2 Pawn uh White
doesn't have time to go on a checkmating
odyssey of his own Bishop to G8 does not
work that's White's idea but it's too
slow black delivers mate in two with
Queen to F1 check and Knight to F3 so
Queen A7 now magnus's only move both
sides walking that tight rope Queen A7
defends the F2 Pawn so I think process
of elimination Magnus has to find it I
was expecting him to react kind of more
uh dramatically there on the camera
Robert because I think he missed this
idea for black he's lucky that Queen A7
clings on the queen defends the dark
squares the bishop defends the light
squares so Black's attack not decisive
but this could still go either way and
the fact that Magnus has not made his
move already it indicates to me that
you're right that he is fortunate at
this point he went forward but he's the
one with the less safe King it doesn't
seem that way but there's a black king
on H6 and yet there's no check against
it and this Knight d2 move and queen A7
another accurate response I mean these
players are playing extraordinary chess
it's not something that I say lightly
the every single move has been an
accurate decision and this queen on A7
for white if it can come back to D4
there are threats against this black
king Bishop to G8 is not available I
just want to quickly show that if we can
while we just all ra is on the clock
that your point is really well taken
David that a bishop to G8 move would
actually lose the game for white right
away so I'm just going to show what
happened in the event of the bishop
leaving Queen check King H2 the White
Queen does protect F2 but the bishop was
needed to protect F3 that is a Checkmate
the queen takes care of these squares
and the king is hunted by this Knight on
F3 so this would be Devastation for
Carlson he is not going to fall into
anything like that but I I think David
your point is is super well taken that
Raza his King is somehow safer and it's
the white king that always needs tending
to from both the queen and the bishop
that's right and uh I think ala here
he's working out who a queen exchange
might favor white does have the option
at some point of throwing a queen to E3
check in and yes black is a pawn up on
the queen side but if Black's pawns
don't run then uh White's King will
Journey over Bishops Thrive over Knight
with pawns on both flanks the Black
Knight almost trapped actually Behind
Enemy Lines if the Queens disappear I
think otherwise alera would have already
played the most natural move Queen to E5
centralization for black preventing your
main idea there Robert Queen to D4 is
probably White's next move if you do
nothing so uh I like Queen E5 hitting
the bishop hitting the pawn on B2 uh
he's just calculating end games he's
calculating whether this move allows
Bishop to G8 for example and uh in the
end he does play the most instinctive
move but backed up by calculation the
clock's though getting dramatic one
minute against just under two minutes
and uh what are you predicting here
feels like a draw Still Far Far Away uh
maybe even the least likely result it's
still Robert so much drama on the board
these positions always amuse me because
the engine says yeah take your choice
seven options all of them are equal and
then you make a move like Bishop G8
without the computer by your side and
queen E4 check and it's the white king
that gets in danger so look at Magnus
Queen C5 the engine it doesn't budge the
best move King G7 back not allowing the
queen to deliver a check so both sides
continue to play Perfect chess but I
will say that it does feel like Black's
position is is better you're up a pawn
suddenly there are threats like A3
trying to take advantage of this one
little Pawn on B2 it is covering both of
Black's extra passers on this side so
one Pawn takes care of two until I throw
away a pawn just to Spring free a passer
I think I would do it now David yeah I
think that's a great call Robert Magnus
does have this mechanism up his sleeve
that I'm really surprised to see this
last move Queen to A5 I thought this was
the perfect moment to bailout to escape
with a draw Queen to A7 check forcing
the black king back to H6 Queen backs C5
threatening Queen to f8 and we'll see a
dance between the White Queen and the
black king uh replying to the Queen's
threats uh but Magnus this last move
indicates he's playing for more but risk
is involved if you play for a win uh in
such a wild position especially with
kind of mutally vulnerable Kings and
your move on the board nice call
deflecting that B Pawn uh uh no more B
for bodyguard there the black seor
therefore will be allowed to run through
I think Magnus will be regretting this
decision uh the B Pawn once it takes on
A3 what else simply you can't take with
the queen you've got to protect your
Bishop then it's just a race and black
is clearly ahead in the pawn race and
important to note the Knight on D2 can
be captured but that's how you lose
games because black will take back on B2
he could probably even push the pawn to
A2 and the bishop on D5 will be loose in
the end while the White Queen does
everything it can to stop the runaway
pass Pawn so less than 30 seconds for
white in this game he does take ALA he
pretty much pre moved the pawn to C3 so
where is the draw I see the engine
saying it's equal and I guess David it's
your plan from earlier the black king is
a bit too out in the open yeah with such
a weak King it's going to be hard to
play for a win otherwise FIA could push
his C Pawn but uh it looks like that's
playing with fire it looks like you're
really living life on the edge I don't
actually see the Checkmate I've got to
admit Robert after PA to C2 trying to
deflect the White Queen away from the
defense of her Bishop but Alara under 20
seconds now surely he cannot take that
risk the professional approach the
recommended approach would be to retreat
the king repeat once and then decide but
he's pushing he's allowing Magnus to go
for M and he's Magnus is blundered oh
and Magnus missed this simple quiet pawn
move the black king is safe there's no
Bishop check because the Knight and the
bishop will be hanging if the queen
tries to stop the C but he can't even do
that cuz the only square is covered by
The Black Queen is completely winning
for FIA now now wow don't try this at
home the black king is literally living
life on the edge but Magnus can't
Checkmate it he's not in time there's
nothing to do black makes a new Queen
two queens are better than one this is
going to be a win for ala was a perfect
game until this one moment and Magnus
finally reacts shakes his head he knows
this is gone one mistaken he he resigned
M didn't he want to play on he did not
want to see the second Queen appear and
Ali Raza fua with the black pieces in
game one David that was a perfect game
from him that was a perfect game 99%
accuracy from Alara in such a wild
complicated position the price of one
mistake is so high and this is the
result allera strikes first
Robert that was Unreal I mean that whole
game 41 perfect moves from the black
side Ali Raza fua he's on his last life
Magnus he has two because he came
through the winers bracket but it's Al
Raza who jumps out to the early lead and
it's just what the fans wanted to see a
Clash of Titans but right now it's
Magnus Carlson the long time world
number one who's on the back foot he
just couldn't find the perfect defense
when the pass Pawn started running yeah
wow it literally was just one simple
mistake Magnus there we see his reaction
to it but we were talking about it for a
long time it was building it was coming
it was the type of position where you
have to be 100% accurate just to survive
and ultimately alaza didn't make any
mistakes Magnus only one but that cost
him that's how high quality this game uh
this kind of game of chess is rapid
chess especially and how on form ala is
right now uh just incredible Robert like
I'm still in shock I thought that would
fizzle out towards a draw I thought ala
was about to bail out with a repetition
of moves but nope one ambitious move
Pawn to C2 he timed it perfectly when
Magnus was down to 10 seconds and just
uh no reply even the world number one
he's human ever so quickly I want to
show what Magnus needed to do and just
let you all know how difficult it is
even for the highest rated player in
chess history that when the black queen
was running away there was only one
option for Magnus Carlson to stay alive
and it was not an easy one so for for
Magnus he just couldn't find his only
move to survive and it was in this
position where he needed to play G4
check giving away either of these pawns
and after the king takes on G4 he needed
to find the queen sliding back checking
the king and the Knight trying to stop
the pawn all at once it doesn't end
there because the black queen can
intercept but somehow F3 check forces
the king away and this queen is captured
a new one appears and yet it is still
even that is how difficult chess can be
Magnus Carlson did not have time to
calculate anything like this variation
and there were still so many others that
he would have had to work through so
alaa he earned that full point we're
heading into game two Magus Carlson
knows that he needs to mount to come
back and he's going to have black in two
of the remaining three games David yeah
he needs to up his game Magnus he was so
close to perfect there nearly held a
draw but as you said when it mattered
the moves were non obvious the moves
were not natural and uh yeah Magnus was
the first to slip but we all know an
angry Magnus is a dangerous customer and
we start the second game Magnus with
black employs the caroan defense he's
actually lost games to alera in the past
on the Champions chest door using the
karukan so um a popular popular opening
amongst players of all levels a lot of
streamers is their favorite shout out to
Gotham chess Dina bellink Kaya and
others but yeah Alara is an expert from
the black side to a risky choice and uh
okay Robert a locked structure another
blocked position but uh what do you make
of this choice is this Magnus aiming to
strike back
quickly I was not expecting Pawn to A5
and then Pawn to A4 this sometimes does
happen in these variations but Magnus
you he's playing on the flank so I tend
to enjoy these positions as a
commentator I struggle with them as a
player because as black you need to make
this super committal move Pawn to F6
just to try and gain some space for your
pieces there's this nasty Pawn on E5
that's stopping a bishop from developing
to D6 it was stopping the knight from
getting to F6 because the pawn was
threatening it so David I know that
you've liked yourself a little carican
in the day are you liking magnus's
Choice when he might feel like he's
ready to strike in game two I do quite
like magnus's choice and uh the fact
that allera paused for a little bit uh
also would have been encouraging for
Magnus uh this line with the black porn
coming to A5 and then a quick break with
F6 I call it the elov line uh because
pav elano the Ukrainian Grandmaster uh
he put out some notes he uh kind of
pained uh this variation he really tried
to promote it among some of his students
as well so some risk attached as you
mentioned very risky with black look at
the kingside pieces all fast asleep
hibernating it's winter in Europe after
all those pieces just kind of staying at
home warmth from the cold but they need
to develop at some point Magnus needs to
get them into action especially since
the center is now going to explode R it
so from my experience I've actually had
up until this last move from Ala I've
had this position before um a lot online
and Blitz and yeah it's Frau it's uh
yeah fra with Peril you really need to
be accurate here as well and Magnus you
can see him on the camera not entirely
comfortable um I wouldn't say this is
his style
Robert no because in these types of
positions and you called it the El yanov
line shout out to pav El yanov who at
his Peak was the top 10 player in the
world
2760 Fay rating in these types of
positions you often need to make a move
like G5 and with your King still in the
center you're asking for trouble this is
not fundamentally sound chess remember
what Magnus said about Dennis lazovic
play he said he's so fundamentally sound
he just plays the position he's not
trying to take unnecessary risk this is
a necessary risk in many of these lines
just to gain space to help your pieces
develop but David it's not easy to push
a pawn when your king is still in the
center and you're opening up even more
lines against it yeah I think uh Magnus
will have known that G5 is maybe the
principled thing to do it's the more
consistent thing to do once you've said
a push some pawns you might as well say
B and start throwing more pawns forward
but um as we mentioned not his Natural
Instinct Mike m Carson he wants to have
more control he wants to kind of be the
one dictating the pace minimal risk
involved um it feels Robert that he's
been riled Magnus it feels like he's
trying to fight fuja on his Turf in
these wild imbalanced positions where
fua is the one who thrives um of course
fuja was uh saying in his interview just
a couple of days ago that he feels
Magnus has improved in these more
chaotic positions of late but it is a
dangerous strategy um do you think this
is just the tournament situation Magnus
having two lives feeling kind of more
freedom uh to play in this Fame two
lives two days off traveling maybe
losing some of your Rhythm but as Magnus
himself said that even when he was
playing he didn't quite feel the rhythm
he was a bit shaky at least relative to
his lofty standards so I do think it's
the match situation that even if Magnus
loses this four game match we should
remind all of our viewers that if ala
takes the first match there is going to
be a reset a best of two then so Magnus
he does have that extra life and for ala
he's just bringing the battle to the
number one rated player in the world and
it's purely Ali Rea style so far in this
match and night G6 Justified but David
I'm already looking at all sorts of
variations with trades and this black
king of the center this Pawn on E6 that
if it remains there can be loose
optically I like White's position and
yet the engine says black is doing just
fine yeah and Magnus I guess we have to
trust him yes it's not his type of
position but as long as he can survive
this initial stage emerge uh there we go
with all of his pieces intact developed
they've certainly woken up from their
Slumber and then yeah black might well
just be in decent shape I don't like the
look of the black E6 Pawn the backward
Pawn there the square in front of it
nice juicy Outpost for white pieces but
other than that fundamentally we
mentioned that word earlier the rest of
magnus's position is quite sound and uh
yeah I think it could have been a lot
worse I was fearing for him just two or
three moves ago allara I didn't really
like the fact that he kind of traded off
on F6 on black terms and then retreated
his Bishop to G3 it Felts like he lost a
little bit of uh kind of speed there and
um yeah of course he's ahead in the
match Al he's the one now who doesn't
need to take risks but uh yeah magnus's
opening risky but potentially Justified
Rob and that E6 Pawn that you are
justifiably worried about is so weak
that Al is willing to double and isolate
his Pawns in the center just so the pawn
loses its Defender alza could have taken
and maybe if Magnus doesn't take the
bishop first can't take in a future turn
but that would fix Black's Pawn
structure by putting this Pawn on F5 so
this backwards Pawn is so vulnerable
that ala is doing everything he can to
leave it in place and David in the
bullet Chess Championship ala fua beat
Magnus sent him down to the losers
bracket and then the losers bracket
final Magnus did take down Ali Rea so
these two have history between them
they've exchange victories for Magnus
Carlson he knows that you know he can
take down Ali Rea he can land a comeback
but in this position the after the last
trade of Bishops here are you seeing any
Clarity and does that make you choose a
side in this game wow I was about to say
this trade surely favors white now the
dark squares in the center are under
White's gaze under White's control long
term but then I saw magnus's last move
and uh yes the evaluation bar slightly
crept up on the white side but you can
see the outlines of a mating net Robert
the white king the open H line if the
black queen nice you got there uh before
me Queen if it lands on H5 suddenly I
will be sweating if I were uh in white
shoes right now you see the Black Knight
black queen combo just uh wrecking just
uh creating Havoc over there so Pawn to
B6 a really slow move from Magnus but um
yeah he's got a well defined a clear
plan and we've talked about it before
that is essential in Rapid chest
suddenly fuja is his turn I don't really
see what white does next you would love
to somehow trade off the queens and uh
just kind of uh install a knight on the
beautiful E5 post but not right now
Magnus feeling the energy um these last
few moves I quite like the way they've
gone for black despite the evaluation
bar I love that move B6 because a pawn
three squares away from a night
dominates that night no forward progress
for it it also opens up the seventh rank
that may seem unimportant but in some
future positions a rook lift and darting
over to the king side there is the
making of an attack over here so uh for
Magnus I'd probably just bring my queen
out I'm not sure if it belongs to F6 or
D6 but the point and he goes to F6 the
point is uh one that you've made before
this queen if it can somehow gets the H
file there will be threats but for now
this Knight on F3 it's too strong it
covers the square it stops the queen
from joining and your plan David here it
is a queen trade it's time to grind like
a Grandmaster that's right the plan has
been foiled really clever play there I
think pragmatic play by fuja and uh
again tip for everyone at home try to
work out your opponent's plans because
that makes your own plans a lot clearer
you sense the danger you ward it off a
mile away and that's why the Queens
disappeared ala was scared of getting
checkmated now a set of Rooks have
disappeared I'm slightly surprised
Magnus traded on White's terms there
he's happy to go passive for one move
with the black Rook U but then again for
now the white Knights aren't really
jumping forward and uh the black king is
soon going to try and evict that white
Rook from uh behind those Enemy Lines um
still I slightly prefer white Robert I
feel that fua he's removed all the risk
you mentioned grinding uh this type of
end game is unclear yet who's playing
for the win but uh loving this Knight
maneuver the Knight was dominated by the
B6 Pawn ala at least he has clear plans
of improvement here and we see because
of the blue arrow that black only has
one move to keep this relative balance
white is ever so slightly better this
black king would love to get to the F7
square but then Knight G5 checks the
king while protecting The Rook at the
same time so that King can't enter he
can't take away the G5 Square because
then you blunder a knight on G6 so there
is a bit of frustration here for Magnus
and it's not just the way he's looking
on camera I'm just trying to work my way
through his position that you saw what
the computers said F4 here not an easy
move to play because white has a
weakness Right double pawns we typically
don't like those but you're allowing
white to UND double the pawns just to
get your knight into the position and
Magnus Carlson he makes these tough
choices look easy he gets the
exclamation point and David I really
like that move yeah really Classy Touch
there from Magnus it's something we've
come to expect from him and uh I think
with relative confidence we were kind of
uh process of elimination we were
thinking he would find it but here we go
rather than allowing the Black Knight
into the game fua he doesn't care about
double pawns that's a minor
inconvenience he's just improving the
white Knights and the Black Knights uh
the counterparts here Robert still a bit
stuck if the black G6 Knight moves white
Rook enters the seventh rank we talked
about seventh heaven uh suddenly the
white Rook will sneak behind over to the
queen side some real targets over there
so still The Dilemma for Magnus what to
do next do you get itchy fingers do you
start pushing some pawns on the queen
side or do you just sit and hope that
white cannot improve his position um
we're talking about grinding right now
it's fua doing the grinding to the Grind
Master himself Magnus
Carson the grind Master now that is a
quality nickname and Magnus he chooses
to retreat with his knight any pawn push
on the queen side has a problem if you
ever push the C5 C6 B to C5 you drop the
B Pawn if you push the B6 Pawn to B5 you
hand white this juicy outpost on C5 so
first things first let's get the Knight
back black has the bathtub Pawn
formation from A5 over there to D5 so
that is uh keeping him in this game
because wh's pieces cannot actually make
progress so easily without trading them
off and we have seen a trade of kn here
is a big question David would you take
with the pa the
KN both are forcing moves Pawn takes E5
I would look at maybe first because it
attacks the Black Knight and that's the
high value piece it's very forcing but
the Black Knight will most likely
centralize or hop back to where it came
from G4 and you've committed a lot yes
you have a pass Pawn with white but it
could potentially be a weakness taking
with the white knight here Robert
equally attractive I've got to say it's
a basically a coin TOS that taken with
the Knight looks like it wins a pawn uh
just x-ray vision like you're pointing
out there with the white Rook C6 or B6
pawns will drop I guess Magnus then will
push one of those pawns not sure which
one it's going to be but uh maybe B5
here C5 he's got to push one before it
drops fu is asking questions I've got to
say I'm surprised the evaluation bar is
almost in the middle because Magnus he's
on the brink already if a pawn drops I
think he's lost I think he's
busted it's like the first game this is
not my arrow it's telling us this is the
only move for black to really have
equality here but that's not an easy
move to play because even Rook takes C6
if we start trading off pieces yes an A4
Pawn is hanging but this may be hard for
visualize the White Knight that takes a
rook on C6 will take a Pawn on A5 after
that David to my eyes this looks like if
I didn't have the engine off to the side
of the board I would say that white
should have the upper hand here as you
said C5 that really does not look
appealing as the B6 Pawn will drop and
B5 I don't fully understand I'm going to
be honest with you
what blackhe s after Rook takes C6 this
was incorrect but an impossible choice
for Magnus yeah a really tough choice
and I agree with Magnus here that C5 is
the more natural move at least the black
Rook is smiling the black Rook is happy
about this development uh that it will
land on an open file but fuja goes for a
race and okay C2 is attacked is he going
to close that line by planting something
on C6 whether a white Rook or Knight or
blue arrow strikes again Robert Pawn to
B4 just creating a pass born at any cost
and a race begins and there's a really
important point in aspect of this
position the black king has no LT No
Escape Square so even if black were on
the turn Rook takes C2 would not be
available as Rook B8 would be a back
rank Checkmate so B4 yes the black pawn
could take white will not even take back
push the a pawn up and black doesn't
have too many pieces to stop it The Rook
on C8 doesn't want to sit passively in
the corner absolutely not that may be
what's required of it typically you want
to stop pass pawns by bringing your Rook
behind them but as we just talked about
there is a back rank Checkmate to worry
about so David I'm not sure if alizza
will play B4 here Knight C6 is extremely
tempting it's a safe move but if he
finds B4 he may knock Magnus out it's
his type of move Robert uh okay he plays
Knight C6 like you said equally tempting
B4 I was going to say he loves the races
he loves the most ambitious moves and um
yeah Knight C6 I think if if it wasn't
for the fact that this looks like it
just wins a pawn then I think ala would
have found that winning blow Magnus we
saw him on the camera suddenly he's
perked up slightly he was head in hands
he looked despondent he looked really
depressed with his position but suddenly
maybe sensing that he's not completely
dead yet so Knight to C6 the question
for black is how to react both pawns are
hit the D4 Pawn I guess maybe the more
edible one uh not to allow the black
Rook to capture on C2 but there will be
a reply he activates the black king good
good end game technique in general
Knight takes D4 now met by Rook to C4
with a double attack so maybe fua just
wanting a bit too much control and uh
understandably so he's a point up of the
match Robert but do you feel this missed
opportunity will come back to haunton
I'm still looking at this with great
chances for white Rook B7 check the
black king can't go forward because of
fork on E7 you can't go back to G8
because of the same Fork on E7 so king
f8 or King to E8 but now your king is
cut off and especially if you go King f8
Knight takes D4 comes with Knight E6
check next winning the G7 Pawn so David
this is again a position I'm like Get
Away computer evaluation this is not how
the players are looking at this Magnus
he is desperately trying to find a way
to survive and that survival may require
him to lose a G7 pawn and David I think
we could say as competitors that is an
unpleasant decision to have to make
really unpleasant and uh you mentioned
what's going through the players Minds
Robert I think Magnus in his mind it's a
two res position he knows if he plays
really really well defends resolutely
tenaciously fights for his life maybe he
gets a draw but I think he's not even
trying to win this game anymore he knows
he's on the back foot the black King's
on the back Rank and that pawn has
disappeared White's temporarily a pawn
up black regains it but the Rook is so
far offside and Robert The Profit the G7
Pawn Falls as well fua is a pawn to the
good and he's the only one who can win
this game baring a miracle it's just
about whether it's enough this extra
porn it is doubled after all on the G
file definitely great chances though for
white I'd be very curious if someone
could put this position in the engine
with the pawn on F3 rather than G3 white
probably just is winning the game but
now the Black Knight has too many access
points E4 we'll check the king hit the
G3 pawn and the C3 Pawn for good measure
if white is forced to defend the pawn
this way this is actually a pin not a
typical pin that we see but Knight E4
check taking a Pawn on C3 may be
available for black so what a defense
here from Magnus bringing his King away
from his pawns just because he has this
lovely tactic at the end to scoop up a
C3 Pawn if the white Rook touches down
on B7 wow Robert that's an essential
detail because otherwise yeah white
would just be winning he plays Rook to
B7 anyway and we're going to see this
appear on the board no need to even show
it Magnus is going to take on C3 next he
can pre moove that no matter where the
white king goes he needs to regain the
material balance here Knight takes he
you're really lucky that you're pinning
and winning back the pawn but the white
king will start activating now it's
still far from safe here for black so
Magnus has landed a nice trick I'm
surprised he didn't take on C3
automatically here Robert looks far
juicier looks far more important than
the G3 Pawn the doubled one over there
and now I'm expecting the white king to
wander forward the black king stuck on
the back rank another Factor you
mentioned could well be an a mating net
if white gets two more moves three more
moves a king on D6 Knight on E6 that
would be Checkmate so watch out Magnus
Carlson this doesn't look that easy I
again I'm looking at the evaluation bar
oh it's equal it's just a draw no this
isn't just a draw with optimal play
Magnus can hold this but David the
carpet is rolled out for this white king
the H7 Pawn is loose and then these
double G pawns can strike and actually
having two G pawns can be valuable Rooks
as I said they like to stop pass pwns
from behind but when you have two of
them you can't quite get there in time
in many positions so Knight to A4 I
would push this Pawn to B3 just keep
that pawn on a defended Square while
attacking the Knight and later white can
go after Black's loose pawns I think
that there are very good winning chances
for ala fantastic winning chances the
Black Knight attacked I'm slightly
surprised I don't see the kind of
circuit for this night I don't see where
it really wants to go to Magnus oh
beautiful move rob it tactics
Gore what a f he stopped the
infiltration of the king and he's trying
to park his work on e4 with cck to win
this Knight give a knight to get a
knight David Magnus Carlson just when I
was saying it looked like he was in some
danger he finds a lovely response now
his Knight is free to get back in the
game it continues I don't think that
there's a draw in the near future
available to Magnus and he's down to a
minute and now 23 22 seconds he's in
time trouble Big Time trouble position
trouble and this is where we talk about
in the end game active versus passive
pieces Black's King is purely passive
look how dominant whites are centralized
Knight controlling eight squares for
white the Black Knight sideline the
white Rook cutting off the seventh rank
uh the Kill Zone for the black king yeah
still some trouble Magnus has done
everything perfectly since he arrived in
this difficult end game to uh kind of
guide this game towards safety but still
how frustrating is that you play so many
kind of incredible moves and you're
still defending you're still on the back
foot Knight C3 I saw the bariz slightly
there Robert is it just the fact that
white can again for what feels like the
millionth time right now go up a pawn
Rook takes
H7 yeah Rook takes H7 is hanging and it
can be captured I was wondering if black
is desperately trying to trade off the
knights Knight E2 it looks clumsy you're
sort of walking into a pin but I believe
that black can get away with it so that
might be magnus's hope in this position
I think that ala would be well advised
to keep some of these pieces on the
board but you have to be extra careful
for Magnus Carlson because in the back
of your mind you're thinking what trades
can I allow if you are down upon trades
usually favor the side with the extra
material and Alara he's about to join
Magnus in the one minute Club it's
getting to a bullet scramble soon yeah
it's incoming guaranteed the scramble he
doesn't play your knight E2 move I
really love that one he's trying to go
behind the pass pawns as you also
indicated normally good classical chess
wisdom but you're sidelining your Rook
it's a bit of a lengthy process here and
uh White's front Gorn the Forerunner
there can start sprinting up the board
I'm not sure whether now on the next few
turns it's also tempting to threaten
mate in one why not just in case the
opponent's Prem moved King to E6 the
opposition there we go he plays it uh
big throut background Checkmate the
black king has to dodge that opposition
it was stared down but it's walking into
the firing line here Robert the White
Knight is coming into F5 this looks
super scary for that black
monik and it's apparently a huge mistake
and Knight F5 it says that white is a
pawn to the good and has a big Advantage
here and Knight F5 threatens Checkmate
once more the black king can step aside
but after Rook G7 check I think the
black king would be forced in the corner
so this is good play from Magnus Carlson
when you're worried about your king
safety You' prefer to be in the center
of the board but also some nice play
from Ala fua he's going after the
weaknesses he's really playing so well
today ala this is ala alera for sure
question mark attached to magnus's move
this is the only way to keep the dwn
intact but there we go Blue Arrow again
push push him baby Pawn to G4 White Pass
pawns here are going to win this game he
starts that Journey robt he's so close
now ala you can see him bobbing up and
down on the camera the momentum is all
on his side he's in that flow State Pawn
to G5 keep pushing and it looks winning
for white now where is yaser sah and one
you need him push him baby let's go and
get a new Queen he first steps back with
the Knight and I'm wondering I thought
black would have tried to kick the Rook
out of there instead he gives up the D5
Pawn well could have be captured with
check but why not take with the Knight
the E4 Knight is loose David this is
getting out of control for Magnus
Carlson out of control his only hope is
the clock it's 17 seconds against 40
seconds there aren't that many pawns
remaining so if Magnus can somehow
sacrifice the Black Knight for all his
porns he can draw but Knight C3 a
winning move Robert double attack Magnus
and you see you saw Magnus he just flew
back in his chair and Ali Raza fua has
soared to a 2N lead in this match this
has been one-sided and when we typically
talk about one-sided matches it's for
the world number one but Ali Raza fua he
may be fulfilling his promise before our
eyes he is just dominating Magnus
Carlson wow it's oneway traffic right
now Magnus was always on the back foot
we said he was close to a draw close to
a draw he had to find all these accurate
moves but ultimately yet again he
slipped up and understandably after
being under pressure for so long Alara 2
to zero lead now he only need a draw in
one of the next two games to guarantee a
reset he's starting to look uh like an
underdog no longer and Magnus Carson
really struggling today Robert wow who
would have predicted this I was about to
ask you that we're on the same
wavelength who would have predicted that
Magnus Carlson would be down two games
to none all aliv Raza F needs is a
single draw in the next two games to
force a grand final reset Magnus Carlson
is lucky that he came today from the
winers bracket I should say he's quite
skilled to come through the winners
bracket but this is a one-sided matchup
as I've ever seen and you don't see
Magnus Carlson on the losing side of
those very often so David just Stellar
play from Ala just wonderful play from
alera really high accuracy really high
energy as well and I just wanted to
recap the closing stages of that game we
already talked about White's long-term
Advantage it had been pretty much since
the opening all about white and uh here
he really Moved In For the Kill white is
a pawn up but the black Rook is
attacking these G pawns he first
threatened Checkmate why not in an end
game threaten these little tricks your
opponent might fall into one of them and
of course the black king had to move a
mistake from Magnus maybe did the wrong
side now again Checkmate threatened the
black king running out of squares it
should have moved to G8 instead a check
the white king dodged again Checkmate
threatened on HJ Magnus finally Sid
stepped from all of these with a check
himself and then running but Alara this
move for me was one of the classiest
Rook back to E5 really calm not even
trying to Checkmate anymore changing
Focus going for the black d pawn and
when Magnus reacted it was time to start
pushing not much Magnus could have done
here but the final mistake was in this
position the Black Knight is attacked it
has to move it's a lost position but
walking into the firing line Knight to
C5 was the straw that broke the camels
back Knight C5 on a loose Square Knight
Retreat and uh suddenly a double attack
The Rook hit the Knight hit Magnus
simply had to resign back with night
moves are the hardest ones to spot in
chess as well so credit to fuja ruthless
Killer
Instinct multiple pieces hit at the same
time Magnus Carlson could do nothing but
resign as everything was dropping off
the board what play from Ali Raza fua it
feels like even when he was the one
getting the time trouble he was under
control not easy to do against the
number one rated player in chess history
but fua he's just 20 years old and I
think he's on the rise fuja is
definitely on the rise his players
really singing to us right now and uh
talking of singing opera and chess.com
have collaborated on the internet
browser for chess enthusiasts the
world's first chess browser has chess
integrated right into the sidebar so
you're only ever one click away from a
quick game of Blitz or a puzzle while
you work you can even pin the sidebar
panel open so that you can carry on
reading watching or browsing with Y and
I on the board while your opponent plots
their next move this is available for
Windows Mac and Android so use
exclamation point chess browser in the
chat now to download Opera for free and
take it for a test ride maybe you'll be
able to play just as strongly as
Alara well we know that Opera has been
part of Chess since 1858 Paul morphe
against the Duke of Brunswick but it's
still in the modern era and this has
been our modern sensation Magnus Carlson
the number one rated player for over a
decade he'll need all the help he can
get taking on the 20-year-old Superstar
ol R of fer will he Mount The Comeback
we'll have to see we'll be right back in
a few here at the 2024 Chess
[Music]
Masters
take
[Music]
to
love
the variant Community series continues
on January 4th with crazy house where
you can add your opponent's captured
pieces to your own Arsenal six weekly
Arena tournaments held every Thursday
will be followed by a championship event
with cash prizes including a $11,000
first place prize the third and final
weekly Arenas will be streamer Arenas
featuring gifted Subs as prizes win any
of these events to qualify for the
championship and show the the world what
you've
got join the variant club today to learn
more about upcoming events how to
participate and much much more see you
in the arena on chess.com
[Music]
sh
m
[Music]
a
even though he's on the road Ali Raza
fua looking right at home bming to some
music David he leads two to nothing
against Magnus Carlson here in the Chess
Masters Grand Final and fuja it's his
first lead in The Champions Chester
against Magnus in this match format yeah
fuja is flying right now he's two up
against the world world number one this
is only his second ever Grand Final in
the Champions chess tour he's seizing
the opportunity seing the moment but the
big question is can he keep it up he
needs to win this match put it in the
books first and then win the reset he
just has to avoid that inconsistency
that we've seen from him from time to
time from creeping into his game but
right now he's done everything perfectly
Robert he certainly has his moves have
been perfect and a movement is crucial
to relieving strain on your body the
Titan EV is designed to Pro natural
posture changes and movement so get
involved get secret lab and for ala fuia
these ergonomic chairs I think they've
been doing wonders for his posture and
his play and Magnus Carlson he's been
the Champion's chess t for a while I
don't think he's been this strained in a
while David yeah Magnus certainly
strained and uh Magnus we've seen him
throughout today with great hair quality
uh the floppy look he needs great chair
quality of course to keep to launch this
comeback throughout the rest of the day
so Magnus it's up to him now the
pressure is certainly
on it is on and he cannot even afford a
draw in this next game he has to win
this one and the following game
otherwise we get a grand final reset so
Magnus Carlson his work is obvious he
needs to win there is no other option
but how do you do that against alaa
who's in this kind of form it's not
going to be easy Magnus has tried
everything now he's been really d
Dynamic with the way he started the game
the first game porn sacrifice it was
that piece for three porn kind of uh
imbalance that standoff second game he
went really really kind of wild and
wacky with the opening didn't pay off
now wow a lot of fans will be pleased a
lot of fans will be devastated it's the
London system uh the most Marite opening
out there Robert but one that has
brought Magnus a lot of success I didn't
expect a Marmite reference on air today
David but this London system a lot of
people will be celebrating because there
are many critics out there how could you
play the London it's it's not a real
opening you're just putting pieces on
squares and then you don't know what to
do but for a lot of our newer fans out
there who have just started playing the
game over the last few years it's been
surging in popularity it's not a
frequent customer at the highest level
just because it doesn't have the most
ambition to it but I will say David in
my experience it could be quite nice to
play from the white side when you just
want a game and for Magnus Carlson needs
to get back in the game because he's
down by two points yeah he needs to try
something different that's what we're
talking about he's uh kind of branched
out he's been experimenting a bit Magnus
today but I think the um the kind of
conclusion that he's come to is that he
needs a quiet a game and understandably
so he's been outplayed in two wild
battles and uh now he's posing early
problems to fua I'm not sure how much
experience fua has against the London
system he just wants simple moves Magnus
he wants to get out of the opening alive
in good shape without having to think
where he can just play by instinct no
more calculation no more walking tight
rope finding only moves um I think
despite my LoveHate relationship with
the London system A wise choice in this
next game of course needing to win is
not going to be easy for Magnus but uh
Klo situation already looking positive
Robert already maybe for the first time
forcing fuia to think this
early well what fuia probably was
thinking about is could he sacrifice
this Pawn on C5 instead he defended it
with his Bishop but in many variations
especially in must-win territory and you
see white grabbing the pawn it wouldn't
have been that easy in this current line
black also can take on D4 at any moment
although white will take back with the E
Pawn and we will get a kocon structure
so David wo we saw vinent kimer
yesterday play an F4 move against leavon
aronian making sure that black cannot
gain space in the center and the bishop
on C8 will be passive I have to say I
like the decision from Magnus it's risky
you're pushing a pawn that golden Pawn
that's near your king but you have a
clear idea it's to clamp down and stop
black from Gaining full activity F4 for
the score the stone wall structure um
this has multiple names and uh clear the
dark Square strategy that Magnus is
going for he's going to try and bind
this position lock it down and uh slowly
try to take over territory suffocate
forua later um the E5 Square as you're
pointing out there under lock and key
the White Knight will most likely Leap
Forward into that post at some point I'm
not sure you want to rush that but watch
out for the black king it's committed
early and therefore it's a clear signal
that Magnus can start attacking that
flank that side of the board in the near
future first this dark Square strategy
we mentioned really consistent puts a
Pawn on A3 all apart from one of the
white pawns now are on those darkart
squares and yeah watch out Robert for
those great gift sacrifices the white
Bishop on D3 maybe the MVP the most
valuable piece right now it is because
the bishop on C8 it can go to B7 and we
typically like toan ketto our Bishops
going on the longest diagonal but it
would have stared into Black's own
pieces I love love love this move A5 and
I also really appreciate magnus's retort
he stops the Bishop from getting to A6
and in doing so the evaluation is
growing in White's favor David it's a
must-win game normally you Castle King
side you play a slow game can Magnus
Castle Queen side throw all the pieces
at the black king o Rober it wasn't on
my radar until the moment you said it
but now you've said it it's I would love
to see that it's growing that idea in my
mind it's simply oh he goes the other
way understandable this is the default
setting I was about to say I've nearly
never seen anyone Castle quinide in a
London system it's literally one in a
million buy a lottery ticket type of
move but I would have it the white king
would have been safe throw the pawns
forward I once Castle queenside in a you
know a game where it was started with
the Cambridge Springs if I remember
correctly and I got checkmated in the
first 30 moves so I'm not actually
advising it in the sense that it's
always going to be good but in a
must-win game if you play a locked up
position where the likely results is a
draw that doesn't help your cause a draw
is a loss at this stage for Magnus
Carlson and for Ali Rea fua he's done
nothing wrong all of his moves have been
quite natural he brings his Rook to the
only open file and are we about to see
Mass liquidation Rook takes C1 Rook to
C8 David where are the winning chances
going to come from yeah it's uh not easy
it's going to have to be a long grind
especially if all the Rooks disappear um
this one open seile Magnus is going to
be wishing it to stay closed I agree
Robert it's hard to visualize yes white
will have a beautiful piece on the E5
Square I'm expecting the White Knight to
LEAP there maybe now or on the next
couple of moves but what next one good
piece isn't quite sufficient black
hasn't got any real weaknesses um still
black is solid it's very passive it's
not for rouer style talking of who uh is
kind of enjoying this position more but
in a situation where a draw is
sufficient um I think he's fine I think
fuja Robert I can't get that Castle
Queens side Motif out of my head this is
why we kind of wanted to get the king to
the other flank Pawn storm the black
king at least it would have been kind of
uh fast ferocious type of Chess here
it's very stodgy and um yeah I'm kind of
agreeing with this feature chat uh in
the London system you need some exciting
ideas and P A G4 anyway
wow
David I drew the arrow to G4 G5 really
thinking about the other position but
Magnus he's showing that he needs to
throw everything F did to try and win
his idea is the Greek gift sacrifice on
H7 whether that should lead to an
advantage for white is a separate
question his idea is clear and ala he
may not want to exchange pieces in this
manner because if he does in fact take
on G4 and white takes on H7 we'll get a
knight for a bishop trade the black king
will be a bit exposed that could feel
uncomfortable when you only need a draw
but as we say day after day you don't
play for result the best way to secure a
draw is just acting like it's any other
game yeah you have to get it out of your
mind otherwise you act too passively too
tentatively too negatively and uh Robert
maybe we just take the opportunity to
point out this tactic put it on the
board because G4 does look like a porn
blunder after all ah ala Dodges it he
doesn't take the pawn a missed
opportunity because actually this might
have been a case of taking the bait kind
of uh taking up the challenge would have
been objectively strongest Knight takes
G4 would have allowed this Greek gift
sacrifice luring out the black king into
the open walking into a KN check but
after the black king Retreats and uh the
Black Knight is captured back to level
material I'm not sure what black should
be doing here but at the very minimum
you might be able to play Knight to F5
into H6 and uh White's position is
actually riddled with weaknesses so as
long as you don't get checkmated black
suddenly doing well The Bishop's going
to come to life fire A6
and this was a missed opportunity at
least according to the computer but a
difficult one for fuja so let's go back
to the game um already he's not
punishing Magnus he's not trying and wow
Magnus has played the move Knight to G5
insisting Robert on some form of attack
but it looks a bit
farfetched I really enjoyed how you said
I don't know what black should do and
then play at the perfect continuation in
that analysis with the Knight rerouting
but Knight to G5 here it's allowing
black to double White pawns but whenever
you have double pawns you gain open
files so F takes G5 next will make this
Rook on F1 a much stronger piece as it
can stare down the length of the file
the bishop on D3 is also going to be a
better piece aiming towards the black
king and at some point H4 H5 I know you
don't usually see someone attack on the
side of the board that King is on but
that becomes an option this Knight can
sink its teeth into the E5 square and it
still remains somewhat of an outpost
depending on how black proceeds so I
have to say that that Magnus does have
some winning chances here and ala he
needs to play accurate chess from here
on out otherwise he's in some dangerous
positions yeah Alara still needs to be
accurate of course he's also three
minutes down on the clock so dramatic
times for him maybe finally the nerves
slightly uh kind of sneaking up on him
here then again his position is still
fundamentally sound black will aim to
meet any flank attack with a strike in
the center black has a huge threat now
uh I think strategic in terms of the
match situation if he gets one more move
Pawn to E5 that you're highlighting
there breaks open the center then it's
only the white king that's going to be
feeling uncomfortable and Magnus
therefore has to act energetically
himself if black occupies the center
breaks things open Advantage black so
Bishop to A6 switching attention first
from the King side Robert trying to
attack there didn't work out now he's
going to the other side of the board
Magnus full board Vision what do you
make of this trying to trade off Black's
bad
Bishop I like it because bad Bishops
defend good pawns or in this case good
squares a White Queen on A6 is going to
poke at this loose B6 Pawn so there are
clear plans for Magnus he is trying to
invade on the queen side while the
center remains closed can he keep it
closed forever that is a question I
think is answered with a likely no so he
is trying to quickly head on over to the
queen side and cause problems I think
that black can exchange Bishops I know
the queen on A6 looks threatening but
once you move your knight out the way I
do believe black has everything under
control at least for the time being and
ala big moment here does he get Ultra
passive with Rook to B8 no he first
brings the Knight back and David if E5
comes next I don't think black is in any
danger whatsoever yeah and uh like you
say once the opponent kind of once you
figured out what the opponent wants you
stop their idea at any cost Knight to F3
but black reinstates that idea of E5
trying to uh open up the center given a
question mark Robert and the bar
noticeably creeping up fua he's had to
to speed up his uh his moves due to the
clock situation but is this a mistake
does Magnus suddenly have an opportunity
I'm looking at moves like Rook to C8
trying to get in round the back um Queen
to B7 looks tempting to try and uh there
we go Queen B7 on the board trying to
hit the black queen Rook C6 now a
massive threat maybe Magnus has gained
enough ground he's really invaded uh
for's Camp wow queen of B7 you called it
that is a wonderful F I was also looking
at Rook to C8 trying to trade off Rooks
on the a final rank of the board to make
the black king feel somewhat unsafe a
queen B7 a very direct threat Rook B8 it
doesn't really help you out here because
white can still bring his own Rook to
the csw and also play Queen C7 trading
Queens will favor white because you have
more activity white control is the only
fully open file here and that means that
you should have the advantage if the
Queens come off so I love this move
Queen to B7 E5 Rook C6 slams down B6
will fall so I actually I'm starting to
appreciate magnus's position more and
more it seems like he's woken up it
feels like Magnus is definitely perked
up he needs to and again a sign of a
champion when your backs against the
wall you suddenly able to turn it on uh
Queen B7 I think unexpected fua look at
the clock time under three minutes now
it was just trying to play too solid
it's not his uh it's not his instincts
Suddenly It's back fired and it might be
too late Robert if the Queens come off
we might see uh kind of rolls reversed
this script
kind of Switched here in the previous
game it was fuja Rook a night end game
dominating with a rook on the seventh
rank now it could be Magnus in a rook
and night end game dominating with a
rook on the seventh rank again um just
Queen C7 I feel is a huge huge threat
and maybe it's best to just play E5 give
up a pawn or two just try to complicate
things I don't think sitting passively
and trying to defend is going to work I
don't think it'll work either and I'm
giving this move that's me doing this
the exclamation point Queen B7 is a
really nice find from Magnus Carlson and
look how it's caused Aliva to pause he
doesn't know what to do E5 Rook C6 at
the very least you're losing the B6 Pawn
maybe the E5 Pawn can be captured next
and he goes for it because David as you
were correctly calling for you can't sit
and do nothing White's plan is too
obvious Here Comes The Invasion and
now's the big question do you take this
Pawn on E5 definitely not with the
Knight the Knight needs to stay put
otherwise G5 drops but do you take this
Pawn or do you take this Pawn or do you
do something else I don't even know what
what other moves come to mind yeah I see
a pawn I want to take a pawn the only
dilemma Robert is that there are two on
the menu and uh which one looks more
tasty he takes this porn but there was a
Grimace from Magnus Carson maybe
realizing it's not as simple uh as he'd
expected black wow Pawn to D4 Oh What A
Move Robert another Pawn sacrifice just
to try and break the black queen out of
jail oh fu is fighting so hard here what
a move d4 just just giving a second pawn
it could have been captured by two white
pieces instead white goes after the B6
Pawn but David what happens if black now
takes this Pawn on E5 as you said the
pieces are breaking
free yeah they're Breaking Free and uh
I'm suddenly uh kind of trying to get
this High School Musical song out of my
head uh that was a real classic the
black pieces they are breaking free the
Black Knight after taking this Pawn
allows the queen to enter the center and
White's King suddenly Magnus is
regretting all those Pawn pushes F4 G4
if he could put those pawns back on F2
and G2 he'd just be winning he'd be up
material but look at it fuja his Queen
the just star here the rest of his
pieces are fast asleep but the queen
alone performing Miracles and yes he's
still a porn down but I don't think the
count matters here Robert if black gets
another move or two Pawn to H5 Rook to
C8 this could even turn uh it's all
about King safety in major peace
positions it's only Queens left uh with
the Rooks I actually really like this
move King G2 I was very very tempted to
play Rook to D5 but then Queen H4 would
have had a check on E1 when the white
King was there Rook D5 becomes a threat
trying to steal this loose pawn and
let's not forget that the black king is
also in danger you have no lift for your
king if you spend a turn making a move
like H5 white still would have played
Rook D5 so Ali Raza he is not taking his
foot off the pedal the queen on B5
threatens Queen E2 not just with one
check but I think a series of
Unstoppable checks which would result in
a draw so Ali Raza continues to play
fantastic chess these first three games
have been exemplary can he keep it up as
there are no checks now and white seems
to be regrouping nicely yeah Magnus is
so strong in Queen end games actually
something we were discussing uh before
today Robert when he's on the front foot
it's all about centralization uh it's
funny that we had that chat off camera
beforehand and suddenly a queen ending
with Rooks it suddenly appears but yeah
White's Queen also doing a great job I'm
loving how f found all the Ang angles
though to try and sneak in and wow
F5 this allows potential Queen trade
this could be
decisive and the engine doesn't hate it
for black but my eyes look like this is
a Magnus Carlson win in the making once
again uh we saw Al a giveaway a pawn Now
Pawn takes E3 is the only move and that
makes sense because A5 is loose hard to
defend and at some point you need to
free up your Rook to go after the uh
White Pawn on B2 so F takes E3 that's
step one that's not what oi Raz was
calculating it was where to put the Rook
instead of going passive he gets active
but David what would you estimate
White's winning chances at because you
are a pawn ahead yeah you are a pawn
ahead you also have a really active King
but magnus's kingside pawns the pawns on
G5 and H2 are so susceptible to attacks
from the black Rook that it might be
difficult and also having a pass Pawn is
going to be great white's A3 Pawn after
capturing on A5 most likely a runner but
Rooks pawns are the worst of the bunch
when it comes to pushing you can only
support it from one side with the white
king but it's an eternity away the white
king is going to have to commit fully to
that side and uh suddenly F will get
counter play on the other flank it's
difficult here I would say it's kind of
50/50 white is 50% going to win 50%
chance it ends in a draw Magnus though
again kind of a a shake of the head and
he goes back goes passive maybe a good
practical Choice Robert he at least
keeps the tension as fua gets under 20
seconds
and we have to note that two seconds are
added to a player's time after every
single turn that's the increment so not
giving alz a easy choices here comes the
black king white could actually get in
trouble in this game if black Scoops up
the king side but here comes the white
king you can actually bring your Rook
after defending this Pawn on B2 so H4
first that makes sense to me to defend
the G pawn and of course Magnus finds it
wow Magnus finds this move it looks like
it just makes the pawn more vulnerable
closer to the black king uh in the
firing line line but nope you kick the
black Rook first and Rook to D4 is
coming next no matter what Robert yeah I
said 50/50 I think this is growing in
magnus's favor the evaluation bar agrees
Rook to D4 establish that control king
of Pawn endings white is clearly winning
the race with the B Pawn a real
Sprinter this is just a master class I
thought it was fizzling out but that
maneuver with the white king going back
in order to go forward so classy and
okay Rook to
D7 he's really asking questions for RIA
down to two seconds Robert this is
really living life on the edge but now
finally control and the B Pawn runs and
look at that he gained a Tempo because
he brought the black king back to H5 and
here he can scoop up the pawn move the
Rook out the way and then run these two
pass pawns on the queen side Magus
Carlson he's done everything right in
this game uh yeah this is just an easy
win for a player of his stature push
your B Pawn give up the G pawn and keep
going it's not about Pawn quantity it's
about the quality you yes about the
quality black has precisely zero pass
pawns right now look at the white Rook
controlling the G5 Pawn helping sheering
the white queenside pawns forward fua
desperately trying to create a pass porn
of his own but I'm expecting that
special move on passant as if the porn
had just moved one square uh Magnus
surely knows about that rule won't have
forgotten about it what do you thinking
about Magnus there we go he captures and
the andb porns run together they say one
Pawn runs faster than two but here those
two on the Queens side Robert way too
far down the board
that's right B7 comes and then Rook C8
shuts down the axis of the black Rook
along the eighth R and the B Pawn
promotes Magnus Carlson he wins on time
but he was winning on the board and look
at this we have a match once again
two-nil start for Ali Raza fuja but he's
the one biting his sweater and this may
be a nail biting finish yeah poor fuja
he played so perfectly the first two
games but that was the goat that was
Magnus really upping his intensity and
suddenly two 21 the nerves will be
settling in how frustrating you think
you're bang in form and then that
happens Robert fua he must be suddenly
fearing that he's working the
beast wow for Ali Raza fuja it felt like
the match victory was going to be in the
bag and then he would have to get to a
grand final reset but will we get the
reset because it seems like Magnus
Carlson's form has reset at just the
right time there was no Advantage out of
the opening it seemed like everything
was under control for ala but Magus he
is Relentless that Queen infiltration
David Queen A6 slithering into B7 that's
really what was able to get Magnus the
upper hand yeah it looked like he was
playing on the king side he committed to
one side of the board but that full
board awareness suddenly switching focus
it was uh like watching a world-class
tennis player kind of batter the
opponent on one side then suddenly
switch things and just overwhelm their
opponent just keeping them off balance
and we saw the looks the reactions there
Magnus so happy with himself finally
things are clicking but fuja wow this
next game is essential he will have
white though Robert and that could be uh
Priceless yes so for ala fuja he gets
the white pieces but we know he's not
always the most solid player he doesn't
like just playing peacefully for a draw
but in that end game for Al I think
that's what he was doing just then he
was analyzing he was looking at the
engine saying what could I have done
differently using game review and I just
want to show that position because it
was really difficult you could give alza
minutes on the clock even hours and you
could still go wrong because it was a
critical moment for him he brought his
King forward instead of using his Rook
to blockade the pass Pawn so okay we
will go into our next game uh that is
starting shortly but for ala fua it it
was a missed opportunity and one that
he's probably going to kick himself
about but I think credit goes to Magnus
yeah credit goes to Magnus fua has lost
some momentum but can he regroup can he
recover quickly this is the real test of
one's metal Robert especially for the
younger generation we've talked about
inconsistency from fuja he barely ever
draws games he tried to be a bit too
solid in the previous one went down to
defeat but now with white he has to go
back to original strategy of attacking
Magnus of playing on the front foot no
more playing for the draw even with
white that won't necessarily work out we
see the Sicilian Defense forja uh will
he go for the open Sicilian it's Back to
Basics back to his stomping ground his
home Comforts of playing really Fierce
attacking chest and wow Magnus is really
raising the red rag to the ball here do
s dragon it's going to be the year of
the dragon I uh have to admit but this
is a risky Choice Robert from
black and it's a choice that is dictated
by the score of the match Magnus Carlson
down by a point a draw is equalent to a
loss for the second game in a row and
look at this H5 taking control of this
G4 Square how many Sicilians have we
seen where White throws all the pawns up
the board and creates an attack Magnus
said no attack for you but in doing so
it's less likely that he safely castles
on over to the king side the black king
may have to stay in the center for a
while David yeah the black king it's
pretty much stranded no way you Castle
kingside after pushing pawns weakening
your own uh kingside flank and Magnus
trading off Knights it feels like he's
in uh kind of known territory here I
must say fresh brand new position for me
but look at this un Orthodox moose
hitting the White Queen this early the
dragon Bishop normally a faneto bishop
landing on the G7 Square not this time
hitting the White Queen preventing
queenside castles one of White's main
ideas in this opening and Magnus
surprisingly trades off he's maybe going
to turn this into a more strategic
battle after the wild promise of the
opening the black Rook is going to enter
the semi-open SE file there we go Rook
to C8 hitting the bishop the black
Queen's going to come out via A5 I must
say opening success objectively Robert I
think black has uh if not equalized then
at least is not going to be hit by a
direct attack as we're used to In the
Sicilian Dragon but is it going to be
sufficient do you think there's enough
IM balance here to hope to win the long
term it looks quite level at the moment
and I was about to say that Magnus
likely going for the queen trade they
say In the Sicilian the skeleton of the
position is often favorable for black
you have traded a Bishop's Pawn the C
Pawn for a Central Pawn this what was on
D4 and so Magnus Carlson he just flexed
his endgame muscles in the third game of
the match why not try for it in game
four I think so many players David they
would think oh Queen's off the board
it's just a draw not when Magnus Carlson
is playing and actually I think as we
look across the board there are enough
imbalances in this it's not symmetrical
Pawn structure that will give black some
chances to try and drum up some
counterplay and winning chances yeah
it's uh that experienced advice that you
dropped earlier Robert you got to play
the position you got you got to play the
board you cannot play for the result
especially at this early stage uh look
at the black king stranded in the center
if you allow white to dodge a queen
trade if you kind of take a time out I
don't know push a pawn to A6 White Queen
will come to F4 white will blow open the
center with Pawn to E5 and suddenly
you'll regret the opportunity oh he
plays Pawn to B5 instead Magnus and I'm
already worried about that black King
Pawn to E5 the blue arrow makes yet
another fateful appearance already the
black king o I'm sweating for it even if
Queen disappear now because the weakness
of the black queen side combined with
the open e and D files look at the white
Rooks so strong right now Magnus maybe
in a bit of trouble according to Alba
shaking his head Robert he's in huge
trouble and the reason why his Rooks are
not connected there's a rook on h8 that
is not participating in this game if you
ever try to Castle down goes a Pawn on
E7 and white can strike on the queen
side at any moment a move like A4 okay I
see the blue arrow that wasn't me what a
move that would be it's the Knight on F6
is under attack the E7 Pawn is pinned A6
is hanging what a ridiculous ridiculous
move oh he misses it fora but Rook to D6
oh one of the
coolest I nearly said a naughty word
there but one of the just the most
magnificent double attacks you'll ever
see it's still available Magnus cursing
to himself here maybe he's just spotted
it shaking his head Magnus I think he's
realizing Rook D6 hitting the Black
Knight hitting the pawn on A6 you pin
here and you win with the E
file he missed it fora Robert but uh wow
missing that opportunity will it come
back to haunt him that's the big
question it's such an awkward tactic
because normally you make a move like
Queen to D6 going for checkmate Rook D6
was just a double attack hitting a
knight and a pawn that was on A6 now
Rook D6 it doesn't actually have the
same threats the Knight for sure is
under attack but there is no second
attack to work with so it's a one move
tactic a cheapo that black will not fall
for and I have to say that White's
position still looks very good David you
asked this question earlier um you know
is there enough life left in the
position I think that's what f is doing
he's sucking the life out of the
position saying let's keep trading if
minor Pieces come off it's easier and
easier to see a draw take form and from
Magnus Carlson there aren't so many
imbalances the more trades that happen
that's that's right Magnus here he wants
more imbalance and when we talk about
imbalance it's in terms of
nonsymmetrical asymmetrical form
structures it's in terms of uh the
selection of pieces often it's Bishop
for Knight or vice versa so I think
Magnus if he gets an opportunity he
would love to trade off for example the
opponent's Bishop for his KN and uh he
would love to push the black hbor
forward he would love to play on the
flag that he's stronger but there we go
Robert he's trading like for like the
night for night uh as long as you keep
doing that as long as it's a rook end
game or pure Bishop end game zero
trouble at all I think it's a really
classy decision from fua considering
that a draw is sufficient look at the
power of the white Rooks so nicely
placed here Black's Rook on h8 still
stranded still trapped hibernating as we
mentioned um this certainly looks like
it's easily within the rounds of safety
for Foria right now it's been the same
the whole way through this Rook on h8 is
not participated it's kind of sleeping
in the corner if you ask me so it's not
involved it needs to get involved but I
don't see a way to make that happen as
the bishop is threatened so if the king
ever castles you drop a piece if the
bishop ever moves there's a Checkmate on
the last rank so Magnus he's going to
resort to pawn E6 and King to E7 those
are his next two moves and then we're
starting to talk about a few imbalances
in the sense that black has an extra
Central Pawn there is this Pawn on E7
white has this extra Pawn on C2 I think
that in the long run these Central
passers they can be pushed a little bit
more easily you can see like the makings
of Pawn pushes here I do feel like FIA
has everything under control but I guess
it gets uncomfortable the longer the
game continues and the more I look at
the clock yeah fua definitely thinking
more in these last two games where a
draw is sufficient than he did in the
first two where he was able to win uh
then again I do love White's last move
King to D2 of course he's going to move
the Rook to safety now but White's next
moves could be king to C3 or King to E3
depending on which side he wants to go
to the white king does have a nice safe
haven on B4 uh potentially there we go
he's headed in that direction he doesn't
care about the kingside pawns they'll
take care of themselves for now but the
white King on B4 will mean that if any
Rook exchanges happen white is going to
win the end game on the queen side and
uh I loved your description of the
sleeping Rook Robert that black rook in
the corner I did actually a few days ago
play against sleeping Magnus the bot on
chess.com
uh it wasn't the best chess player in
the world but that black sleeping Rook
needs to wake up at some point just as
Magnus needed to that but G5 the pawns
at least have uh definitely awoken from
their
Slumber and we can see what Magnus is in
for maybe Pawn F6 Pawn E5 and just put
all these pawns on dark squares you
actually don't know when he is going to
break with a move like H3 just to ask
questions of the white Pawn structure
but ala to this point has responded very
well every single move with purpose this
Rook can join the party on the open a
file David the big question do you play
this Pawn push to H3 well the answer is
clear next move if you're given the
opportunity black is going for it yeah
black is definitely going for that I
don't think that even time to go
harassing white uh that light Square
Bishop Rook to A6 would have run into H3
I'm really surprised fuja hasn't
committed he hasn't blocked off that
pawn Advance the reason white didn't
push a pawn to H3 and uh just totally
lock up black on the king side is
because longterm pawns on light squares
are big targets for the opponent's light
squar Bishop um so Pawn to H3 maybe
objectively a good move but you imagine
the black king getting into G3 getting
into one of those holes those pawns are
doomed long term so fua he's trying to
play flexible chest keeping all the
options open uh he's essentially saying
to Magnus yes it's probably level now
but you are the one who's going to have
to do the hard work and Rook to D7
Robert I mentioned Rook trades long-term
favoring black uh sorry favoring white
because of the active white king are you
surprised by this decision very
surprised and he has to retreat his
Bishop so H3 doesn't have the same punch
as it did with the bishop staring in the
Pawn's Direction but what Magnus is
going for is what you were just talking
about David that if white plays H3 I
think I'm gonna look the engine says H3
is acceptable here but strategically it
is horrible because you see how easily
the black king waltzes its way to a
square like G3 so you think that for now
it's okay but in the long run I'm going
to be in trouble so moving H3 from the
white side super difficult to play
strategically risky I think it's more
likely that ala makes an active move
like Rook to A7 but then Magnus really
can start considering ideas with a rook
lift just trying to get at White
somewhat soft Pawn structure on the king
side yeah you said it before Alpha
Magnus he loves pushing those Rooks
pawns it's his trademark in recent years
ever since Alpha zero in 2019 I think
Magnus will just install a Pawn on H3
maybe after trading on the C4 square and
then he's just going to hope it's two
squares away from touchdown that it
becomes a new Queen in the uh kind of
not too distant future we talk about end
games Robert Magness maybe the greatest
endgame player of all time especially in
these types of end games where it's not
just calculation it's about feel it's
about making uh practical decisions and
there we go Pawn to H3 white will not
take white will not break his own
structure you have to bypass this Pawn
but if anyone can win this end game with
black rob it it is
Magnus I would say very realistic
winning chances for Magnus Carlson right
now and when you're playing against some
of the younger generation just like
Magnus Carlson did to gesh when they
played in the World Cup in certain end
games a youthful player just almost by
definition doesn't have the experience
of getting deep down into these end
gamees so the technique it may be
learned but you have to prove it each
and every time over the board and
there's so many nuances so I love what
Magnus has done here he's created a
weakness on F3 you may be tempted to
push the pawn to F4 but after a series
of Trades watch out here comes a rook to
an open file so Al is trying to be
passive he's trying to defend and he's
thinking that this is the best way to
try and secure that half point but David
it does seem much more natural to play
from the black side the moves come more
easily
yeah fuja he's lost control I think it's
just playing for a draw Robert it's on
his mind a bit too much the last game
the previous game he went into a
difficult end game because he played
negatively passively here with white
okay he missed this beautiful winning
idea of Rook to D6 earlier but in
general he's been happy to trade off
happy to play the safe option on every
turn and there's no safety against the
likes of Magnus Carson so definitely
trend on Black's side the trend is
Black's friend and the king is coming
King into E5 D4 E3
you can see a clear path what is white
doing in the meantime fucha has to
really up his game he's still fine
objectively but 3 minutes on the clock I
do fear for him uh just as you were
hinting at too Robert and there's so
many important decisions in a game like
this F4 Pawn takes do you want to take
with the pawn or The Rook if you take
with a rook I know this may be hard for
some people to visualize then black has
two pawns that are unopposed that can
help each other down the board and if
you take with a pawn ever on F4 after a
trade you open up a g file so there you
always see the downside of certain
decisions and for Ali Raza who is down
under three minutes he is not going to
have an easy time of this as Magnus
continues to press him on the board but
more importantly on the clock yeah for
Rob bit and I also wanted to shout out
your patent recognition that game
against gesh that he ended up winning in
a rook rook and porn ending black also
had the F7 E6 porn combo that started
marching towards the latter stages so uh
yeah feels like a lot of similarity
there good move I feel from fuja the
white Rook didn't want to stay tied down
too much longer on the passive F1 Square
now he's at least seeking counterplay
again a tip for everyone at home don't
sit there don't suffer don't let your
opponent just slowly keep improving
sooner or later you have to uh kind of
step forward you have to ask questions
activate your pieces now Magnus what do
you feel he's going to do tradeoff pawns
bypass this pawn pawn to G4 and you
don't want your pawns on light squares
but maybe at least it keeps more pawns
alive Robert
and I think it's also tempting to look
at Bishop D5 trying to put pressure on a
pin piece but white has the very simple
move B3 so just to point out that you're
not going to win material there to
answer your question directly I would be
tempted to capture I just think that you
may get some imbalances there that if
you play G4 maybe white pushes to F5 and
I don't know if black can connect the
Pawns in time to keep them all safe and
sound it's not an easy Choice that's why
Magnus is spending time and David I have
to ask you as we look at the clock how
how much of a role do you think it will
play I think it's going to play a
massive role uh actually it's uh it's
not obvious but the top players I feel
they play much quicker in positions
where it's very forcing even if it's
tactical and a bit crazy uh they make
good decisions because their calculation
is so fast but when it's strategic
decisions when there's no obvious move
there's nothing forced you have six or
seven kind of very sensible options on
every single turn that's where the time
is burnt that's where actually you need
to uh invest some time you need to have
it saved up in the for later um I mean
look at this now Black's Bishop on a
beautiful Outpost if the black Rook gets
to H1 uhoh White's Pawn chain just
collapses so um there's a clear path a
clear plan for Magnus in terms of the
clock two minutes now for fuja no clear
plan for him and he's just trying to
hold things together a bishop trade here
Robert will not save white
necessarily no because the plan is this
I know that looks ridiculous because a
rook moving on a diagonal but if this
Rook can sit on G2 white will not be
able to take it and that may freeze Ali
raz's pieces in place David does this
remind you of the Champions chess tour
finals from a season ago where I think
Magnus was playing against Wesley so he
had a very similar structure in fact he
had a winning position in that game uh
so this Pawn structure here with that
nasty Pawn on H3 it can create a wedge
and it can hurt your opponent as Magnus
has proven over the years yeah I
remember growing up watching these uh
rapid games where Kasparov in I think
1994 kept in the Sicilian getting a pawn
to H3 and checkmating the opponent now
modern kind of knowledge modern wisdom
shows that pawns on that square in end
games are also a huge Trump up the uh up
the sleep for later has Magnus slipped
up though Bishop to
E2 yes face look at that reaction David
he did not see the retreating move
coming oh my gosh I didn't see it coming
I must admit I thought Black's plan it
was so straightforward so simple he
should have got his King out of the
firing line off the defile pin
and
wow Magnus agreed to draw so he agreed
to lose the match I mean you know you
can lose this game it's the same as the
draw David are you surprised that he
wouldn't even fight I know white
objectively has everything under control
but are you surprised that he didn't
continue this and give it as all I'm
shocked I'm gobs smacked speechless just
Magnus you never nearly see him kind of
willingly admit to a mistake like that
um yes he just blundered a porn but one
move earlier we were talking about how
great his winning chances
were opportunism there from Ala fuja but
so uncharacteristic Magnus he knows we
go again he knows today has just been
extended Robert Alara he didn't do it in
uh in the best fashion it wasn't pretty
at times but he got the job done wow so
unpredictable and lightning fast that
happened remember that before that first
match and now we are going to get a
reset the win probability as you know
ala he's listening to the team working
hard behind the scenes to inform him
when the next games begin but that was
90 plus% in Magnus Carlson's favor I
think that number is going to drop like
crazy because we are gonna have a best
of two coming up Aliva fuia against
Magnus Carlson David do you see Ali
Razer actually potentially being the
favorite now that he has the momentum
yeah we talked about the momentum
earlier he started with a bang he won
two games in a row the win was taken out
of his sales he was knocked back Magnus
struck back and uh that last game it
looked like it was all about Magnus
Carson especially the latter phases but
suddenly fua breathing aside relief he
will believe that fate that Destiny is
on his side in the Chester ball Masters
it was here I really loved White's last
move seeking counterplay remember
everyone don't defend passively in end
games especially if you're facing mnus
Carlson but Pawn to F5 trying to utilize
this pin on the defile and it is hard
for black to win this game I do feel
that maybe bringing the king into the
center was the best bet because now if
white tries the same if white goes after
this G Pawn you are not pinned the black
king can step across to F5 black Bishop
can come into F3 the game is alive you
have great chances due to the thorn in
your side of the white side of this H
Pawn two squares away from promotion
instead Magnus carelessly played Rook to
A1 this is part of the plan Robert
pointed it out Rook to G1 Rook to G2
would be a really dangerous idea but
unfortunately you've forgotten about the
base of your Pawn chain this chain
immediately undermined Bishop to E2 and
nothing to be done The Rook cannot
defend the pawn and due to this pin the
black king and Bishop also powerless
Magnus though offering a draw admitting
that he'd messed up a real shock a real
surprise to see the world number one the
fight sucked out of him like that will
he recover we're on for a reset we are
in for a reset in the Grand Final here
at the ches Masters and for Magnus
Carlson he's been wobbly but in order to
defeat a champion the number one rated
player on the planet for the last decade
it can't just be wobbly you have to
knock him out so Magnus Carlson he came
in with two lives he's down to one ala
fua still fighting he's punching he's
clawing and he has an excellent chance
who will it be Magnus or ala we'll find
out in the flip side of the break this
is the 2024 ches Masters this is the
Grand Final reset just two games remain
between these two who will come out on
top
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome everyone to the first ever
chess.com holiday party we're here with
the eight well seven of the Champions
chess tour flight unless one of them is
not here but lucky for us as Santa I
already knew that one of the gifts might
come in in real handy so what we've got
here is a uh is a gift that keeps on
giving for some lucky lady out there
right there we're going to put Magnus
right here in between Max SE and Hikaru
but let me explain the rules real quick
we have eight numbers in here everyone
here is going to pick a number to decide
the order in which they go to choose the
presents in front the present can be
stolen if you like what someone else
gets you don't even have to pick a
present you can just steal their present
from them but once the present has been
stolen twice it is officially frozen you
can never steal that present again at
the end of the game whichever one of you
gets the number one get to choose
whether to keep your present or make one
final steal to get the gift you want so
I'm going to go around
here I'm going to take the last number
lot like our fair play you know judge
jury and executioner over here right hey
there you go insert joke who's number
one okay Maxine bash the gr starts us
off let's do it well I guess this for my
guests look at that I know what you guys
thought you guys thought you were
showing up and every gift was going to
be a joke nice sauce that's a Nintendo
switch M play that every day I'm Number
Two okay I have the the best number the
worst
number are we found worth than eight oh
eight is the second best oh really yeah
cuz eight you get to have all the
information I thank you I got a box
what's in the box I have a smaller
box I got airpods wow oh sweeter every
white El has to have an ugly Christmas
sweater and you're the one who got it
okay all right who's four
[Laughter]
okay you can cook
tonight what Denis here we go okay it
says
magnet
colti show it to the camera the proud
odor all right hiar is shaking shaking
vag or is he
steing who that
Danny that was not my idea all right I'm
going to to use this one here
certificate of disposition and
Proclamation lord of the bong Cloud
opening okay I'm I a lord of the bong
Cloud here we go Wesley I'm going to
steal yeah yeah it's hard to choose I I
See's airpod okay that's fair okay
airpods have been stolen it's official
game on so we have to keep the game
going so I'm taking your
all
right okay he's rolling the dice he
loves Anish that much okay Dennis you've
been set free oh he got the switch okay
Denis loic officially owes the switch
party in his room tonight I guess I'm
taking he's taking the airpod airpods
are off the table which means Wesley you
have the power to choose a new gift oh
my gosh what is it are you
kidding oh yeah you're paying right yeah
that's okay good keep okay there we go
that's it and that everyone was our
first ever white
elephant
it's down a be he's down two pawns a
couple of checks magnus's King is going
to dance easily out of them take my
queen and give me a new one please he's
losing now he walks right into the and
they know it they know it turn your
boards 909 952 made a big mistake oh and
the bar is going up this is an absolute
Gem of a game Wesley saw has done it
he's going in for the attack but he's
walked into Checkmate black can play
Rook takes
porn one move Checkmate two second oh oh
my God why an arm
in the 2024 Chess Masters comes down to
this Ali reaza fucha lost his first
match of the event against Vladimir
fedos and since then he's been on a
rampage including that match victory in
the Grand Final against Magnus Carlson
we will have a grand Grand Final reset
Magnus Carlson he has to write the ship
here and now as there is going to be a
best of two match if we're tied one to
one we get Armageddon with bidding
everyone's favorite type which of aliv a
fua he's letting his move do his bidding
he is loud he is proud he is stylish and
he's got tactical flare David he has
been a menace today he has clearly
winning is in fashion for FIA and if he
can keep up his play especially from the
first two games then he will fancy his
chances even against the king himself
the king of the Champions chess tour
King of the Chess World Magnus Carson
and it has been done before Maxim bashra
at the end of last season took down
Magnus in two consecutive matches uh we
saw yesterday as well some really really
long games Magnus I think needs to take
inspiration from those games in division
two division three where despite being
ped back the uh players who emerged from
the winners bracket they did write the
ship so uh Robert here a lot to say for
both players but uh I don't think they
have had enough time to calm down it's
just about who can kind of uh get to
terms with this brand new fresh
situation it's been a lot of bad for
Magus Carlson today but there is some
good news that that match is over it's a
thing of the past and we are going to
get a different format the same time P
don't worry we are going to see the
players still playing rapid chess but as
we hit the Grand Final reset they are
playing a best of two games one and a
half points a win in a draw and you win
the Chess Masters if it's tied one to
one we get to Armageddon with bidding
the players I think they would like to
end this in regulation but David 10
minutes 2 seconds at it per move that
rapid time Patrol things happen in a
Flash things happen so fast we saw it
just in that last game where momentum
Magnus was uh suddenly just stopped
brought to a halt by one mistake one
blunder and Aller Razer got to safety
that's how quickly things can turn no
room for error anymore two games is a
pure shootout it uh yeah doesn't provide
any uh margin for error at all Magnus
starts with white Robert can he start
with a win can he start with a bang he
is traditionally a slow starter as we
saw earlier today but this is where he
needs to move through the gears and
bring his best he cannot afford to lose
in this game with the white pieces
against alera fuan and I can't believe
we're talking about Magnus like this
Magnus losing with white but look at him
he does not seem to be the confident
Magnus that has won so many world
championship titles in all time controls
so he trots out the trpovski this bishop
on G5 it could take on F6 at some moment
but for alza he is locked in he is ready
and why should he be scared he just took
down Magnus Carlson why not do it a
second time in just a day yeah he did it
in a 4 game match he's young he's full
of energy can he do it in a two game
match now and uh this is a cousin of the
London system the white Bishop moved to
a different Square different ingredients
but similar porn chain for Magnus Carson
this was the game he won where he set up
this triangle of pawns for white he
later pushed a pawn to F4 will we see
that happen again fua spending a little
bit more time than his opponent at these
early stages trades off a set of Pawns
but what next will black light squar
Bishop come out um yeah who do you think
is going to be the happier at this early
stage Robert well I think that both
sides are sort of feeling the other out
it is a new match we just saw ala fuja
take down Magnus Carlson but you have to
forget about that if you're fuja too
it's not like you have a lead you're
starting from zeros so the opening it
seems standard Magnus Carlson he plays
the Trump Hy even on the world's biggest
stages let's not forget that world
championship match where he played the
Trump Hy in the first game and for Ali
Raza he has never won a Champions chess
Tour event is today going to be the
first he'll have to play sturdy defense
in this first game David I was gonna ask
you do you break the pin with G5 if you
are ala he says no he's playing this
more solidly oh it becomes more tempting
now however Robert once the white King
has committed uh to that flank it looks
like a bit of a sitting Target so Pawn
to G5 I think would be justified but it
depends on your mood you do burn a lot
of bridges fua staying flexible note how
he's trying to provoke Magnus bait
Magnus into taking on F6 because that
would only
guide another black porn towards the
center open up the semi open G file
there and yeah Magnus wisely rejects
that option I've got to say it's the K's
bad structure this Pawn structure arises
from a variety of openings the Queen's
Gambit declined the kocan defense Magnus
is pretty much playing a queen's gamet
declined with reverse colors uh but he
is the world leading expert I'm going to
say in this porn structure at least in
modern times uh so I think a lot for him
to be positive about but porn H5 Robert
this is fuja at least hinting that he
might attack he can at some point
continue throwing pawns at the board but
not yet that point is not now because
the Knight on F3 and look at fuig go he
has this triangle of Pawns here with a
bishop they're all working together
quite nicely it's an odd formation I
haven't seen it very often but a bishop
on F5 helping these pawns everything is
defended so no holes in Black's position
in terms of targets to attack but maybe
some holes in terms of squares the dark
squares we've talked about this them a
lot today that maybe white can use those
to his Advantage if he can keep his King
safe and sound yeah the Pyramid of power
that's what I call that porn chain
Robert and uh actually fuja is the one
of the leading experts in the carakan
defense and in the exchange variation of
the carakan this is a really common
pattern you see this exact porn
structure for black you see the bishop
planted on this F5 Square so he's using
uh kind of all of that experience patent
recognition
from a different opening and he's
utilizing it here against Magnus Carson
so Queen to D2 I think you're right
Magnus is going for the dart squares
watch out for Magnus to play a move like
Queen to F4 even on the next turn
offering a queen trade trying to uh gain
that grip trying to capture towards the
center yes White's got doubled G pawns
they might be even better as doubled F
pawns but this is really the players
just tiptoeing around each other and
just before I could say it fora Castle's
Queen side he means business this is
back to him uh kind of playing
confidently Robert we saw a bit of a
lull from him for those two games he got
the job done with a draw in the last one
but uh after a fast start he quieten
down now he's out for blood again it's
like we're back to the very first game
that we saw today between them where uh
it was a peace sacrifice for three pawns
and then Magnus he went wrong deep down
in that game where he had only one way
out so you see A4 here comes the pawn
Storm from the white side but the
problem is the attack isn't clear B5 the
Knight goes to A5 you have the dark sore
is under control you usually start with
your outermost pass pawn and we can use
that pawn as a battering ram but as soon
as there's Pawn contact black shuts the
door so that is the idea from the black
side and what what black going for the
attack G5 H4 this Pawn is Frozen in play
so David I actually see the makings of
an attack from the black side a little
bit more easily than I see them from the
white side fully agree there's a hook
after all that white p on G3 you hook it
open and uh you drag the H file uh open
for that black Rook Knight H4 a good
move I feel not just to uh block the
advance the continued inevitable advance
of the black pawns but also to hint that
you might trade off a set of pieces and
Black's attack will lose a lot of power
if that does indeed happen how does he
keep pedaling how does he keep uh the
momentum going Robert here for black it
looks like f has done everything
possible to play ambitiously on the
front foot but what next what do they
say a night on f8 the there is no mate a
knight on F1 there is no fun F3 controls
uh this G3 Pawn with the Knight on F1 so
you can boot the Black Knight out of
there so I love this move Knight H4 as
you said hinting at a capture on F5
stopping this H Pawn from pushing
forward and opening up the gateway to
kick this Knight out of G4 suddenly my
mind has changed Magnus makes what seems
like an innocuous move but it carries
several different ideas behind it and
for ala fza is it time to strike with a
move like e five in the center there is
risk to that as well because as soon as
you push pawns you may not have the same
control you did a turn AG
go yeah I don't think it's in his
vocabulary uh backward Retreat Robert I
think Pawn to E5 just go for it it's
what the fans want to see I think it's
his best chance as well to keep setting
these unorthodox uh kind of problems for
Magnus Carson pwn to E5 just going for
Glory breaking through the center you
can play on the king side later I love
that move but uh yeah also a move like
Knight to E7 maybe not for Instinct but
kind of fundamentally sound this
definitely feels like the Cal before the
storm look at those accuracy levels both
players playing provocative ambitious
chess but also just really really strong
chess so um okay P moment and fua clock
time not on his side long think right
now will it be a wrong think that's the
question you're you're a rhyming man
today ever the poet you know it David
Howell is giving us some wisdom here but
it is true that sometimes players they
would make a move instantly in bullet
and then spend quite a lot of time when
they have minutes on the clock I it is a
critical moment so for fuja he needs to
look if this capture is happening and if
he ever has to take away from the center
then that D5 Pawn becomes a Target so
you don't want to capture in that
direction E5 is striking but it's
committ as as I was saying you don't
want to capture away from the center he
actually invites this swap of pieces
David and H4 becomes a threat but how
about these two pawns who is gaining the
upper hand
here I can see why he found this
attractive I can see why he found it
tempting for RIA clear cut plan the
queen is going to slide across to H7 as
well it's got all the outlines of a
checkmating attack but strategically
you're busted now those ugly doubled
pawns um and it's very much a race you
have to Checkmate white before for
example White's able to pick up the F5
Pawn I'm looking at moves like Queen to
D3 or Bishop to D3 uh which has I think
just been played there we go taking the
F5 Pawn will undermine the uh Integrity
of the Black Knights position the
beautiful out post on G4 and if you
can't deliver Checkmate your position
might just collapse so really huge
decision there um I think in the right
Spirit Robert but maybe not the most
accurate maybe allowing a bit too much
fun for white and I guess Alis might
overestimate his attacking chances the
problem is once the F five Pawn drops
white can actually prevent black from
teaming up on the H file and moves like
Queen H7 you're not in time to strike
with this Pawn push to H4 in many of
these positions white can in fact play
Pawn to F3 to challenge this Knight to
force it backwards and then white can
still march forward over on the other
flank where the black king sits lying in
wait for the attack to commence so
Bishop D3 excellent awareness from
Magnus Carlson ala once again long think
will it be a wrong thing
David yeah and you're spinning out the
Rhymes too Robert do feel that that long
thing he had this going for G5 changing
the structure provoking white to kind of
probe at these black weaknesses he might
be regretting it already because look
how much time he's using right now he's
given Magnus kind of something obvious
something clear to do that's the last
thing you want against the worldclass
player Knight to E7 he's M mixing up his
plans now he was going forward he was
going on the attack now retreating going
defending uh going defensive it's it's
kind of inconsistent we talked about his
form occasionally inconsistent foro but
yeah his play here it just feels a bit
wrong and now I'm not sure what next for
white attractive moves would be maybe
either Pawn to F3 if you really want to
kick away that black knight Rook to E6
looks super tempting as well just
entering the black Camp going for some
of those weak black pawns more
importantly activating the other Rook
The Rook on A1 via the E file double
stack them yeah it's suddenly Magnus
with a bunch of extra time he's got
obvious moves fua his Queen's path
towards the king side's also been cut
off I fear for black suddenly even
though I love the uh kind of spirit
Behind these uh these ideas I think it
might be going wrong Robert and it goes
to show how you as a chess player
everyone watching you can't tunnel in
you can't just go for the attack because
you have to watch out for the base of
your position the foundation is Rocky
these double pawns are not healthy as
David just mentioned I love this move
Rook to E6 F3 can be played later but if
you play F3 there's no taking it back
and then the White Knight is a bit stuck
on F1 otherwise your Pawn on G3 will be
loose so uh these are big decisions and
especially when you're touching upon
they can't take it back so Magnus
Carlson thinking here I don't think this
is a wrong time for him to do so he is
up so much time three plus minutes and
rookie six rookie one to follow White's
play starts to come very obviously and
black is on the back foot yeah I think
Magnus here he's just calculating what
would happen after a move like Rook to
E6 if uh F just says okay I've had
enough buildup now it's time to actually
enact my real plan Pawn to H4 blow open
the H file and uh some stuff to
calculate there I do admit so I think
very wise moment for Magnus to pause
he's looking into the future trying to
read F's mind trying to calculate with
Clarity exactly what he should be doing
but the eval bar here I think Robert to
be trusted we sometimes don't say that
in these complicated positions it does
feel like White's got enough control I
don't see the attack yet uh I don't see
black breaking through in time because
White's uh kind of going to gain Tempe
White's going to gain a lot of momentum
hitting that Black Knight on E7 first of
all and this question mark here I think
it's really about the move two turns ago
that G5 Pawn push at this stage it's
difficult for black to play now the
Knight is kicked it goes back and both
of our plans David kicking Knight and
bringing the rook in for white to attack
this loose Pawn on F6 Rook e one next
the harmony is there from the white side
and now H4 it just looks even less
potent because the Knight is on the
wrong Square this on the rim is dimming
Black's attacking chances that Rook
needs an open file not a pawn and a
knight in its path especially if all of
these pawns start collapsing on the king
side over here I think that black is in
some
trouble yeah definitely in some trouble
and uh again it's all about that
momentum it's all about the initiative
uh you want to kind of be consistent you
want to keep throwing things forward at
your opponent as soon as you step back
give your opponent time yeah Magnus now
reasserting control and Pawn to F3 that
move I wanted to mention it did lose a
bit of the eval at least according to
the bar but makes magnus's plan even
more simple it makes the Black Knights
feel really clunky really clumsy and uh
big threats now hitting that black
knight kicking it to C8 I don't know
what the rhyme is for the C8 Square
we've talked about f8 F1 Robert what's
the rhyme for that black I'm not going
to call it a Steve that black knight
yeah that Knight C8 might seal his fate
you're moving backwards when your whole
plan was to unleash an attack where is
that vicious Onslaught where are you
going after the white king that white
king it's it's tucked away right now and
moves like H4 in the near future I could
probably just grab it as your knight is
loose on H6 so there has not been this
happy coordination of pieces for black
the ideas they haven't been uh kind of
in combination with one another and now
white is the one who is first to the
attack carving out light squares and
only white has a light Square Bishop if
you play B6 here there's going to be
future problems on these light squares
if you take you're opening up a file in
front of your King David this is as
unpleasant as a position can
get yeah he does play B6 out of
necessity more than uh anything there
and I don't know how he does it Robert
every game win or loss Magnus somehow
installs a Pawn on H3 or A6 or H6 just
those Alpha zero type of ideas Magnus is
obsessed
and he gets a lot of success from it
look at the White Knight now this is a
real Ste a real stallion jumping forward
hitting the D5 pawn and it does feel
like black is already on the brink of
collapse I'm looking at the clock I'm
looking at the board and it's all going
wrong Queen D7 he's just inviting white
to play the move he wanted to last turn
Knight takes D5 what does he have up his
sleeve Magnus is just going to go a pawn
up material be greedy here why
not greed usually isn't good but in this
particular position I think white can
snag the pawn and Magnus Carlson
successfully does so the pawn is
captured and wow what a move from Ali
Raza Knight to E4 Magnus he doesn't seem
particularly impressed I don't think he
believes in it but what an idea from the
20-year-old player Ali Rea fua he has
disconnected these white Rooks from one
another that means that Queen takes E6
can be played if white just tries to
grab a quote unquote free piece that
Knight on e4 it doesn't drop and so as I
look at this position it's becoming
tactical and Magnus he wanted full
control ala says not so fast wow Alara
we mentioned it he's zoned in he's so
focused on this game he wants it more
than anything this Victory Knight E4
what a cool move just uh chaos button
indeed pressed um we see the eval bar
Magnus whoa Rook sacrifice on B6 I was
going to say he can give up material in
a bunch of ways I did not see this one
he's given up rook for Bishop here or
Rook for minor piece Robert but that
black king is so open what is the count
that move was given a question mark it's
a very difficult position for black this
move makes a lot of sense but I'm just
trying to quickly count the material
black has Five Pawns white has seven so
two extra pawns for white white has this
bishop here black has this Rook over
here so it's two pawns and a bishop for
a rook that's about even in terms of
point value but look at the king safety
Black's King not very safe especially
after this move B5 this Knight Will hop
back to B4 and then it will jump forward
to C6 with a check and a fork and
White's King is tucked away so David it
was a fantastic exchange sacrifice there
from Magnus he responded excellently to
some Stellar tactics from fua so both
players are playing quite well it's just
that fuja never got his attack off the
ground he he was sort of stuck in place
and Magnus has been able to capitalize
yeah Magnus really showing class when it
counts when it matters I love that
three-step idea Robert Pawn to B5 Knight
back to B4 into C6 that's just a winning
uh concept here the black king will not
survive the wroth of that white knight
and okay he's giving up pawns Magnus uh
he's at least opening up the black king
even further but he needs the
Breakthrough suddenly we did that count
and things are getting dramatic Magnus
still down Rook for Bishop but the pawns
are dropping Rook takes Knight is a big
threat uh the white minor pieces a bit
loose in the center Magnus needs a
knockout blow is that still retreating
the Knight back to B four is it trying
to break the white Rook into the seventh
rank somehow the recurring pattern of
The Rook on the seventh rank always
doing the business accuracy required
Magnus needs to stop think and calculate
because this is the type advantage
that's winning but could disappear in
one move it's no longer one-sided
instead of just Magnus pressing forward
stealing a pawn and playing safe for
example Rook to B1 black will give up
the queen down here to get that loose
Knight on D5 and we're talking about two
Rooks versus a queen now White's King is
still safer so you should be happy if
you're Magus Carlson but not thrilled
because at some point a knight to G4
will eliminate the Escape squares for
the white king so we're going to see
some imbalances I think that Magnus he
needs to strike quickly I just said Rook
B1 objectively it might be good but I
would be a bit uncomfortable by that
choice can I throw anything else out I
want to get my Rook to E7 but David as
you pointed out correctly this Knight on
D5 is lose these decisions are not easy
for Magnus who dropped one pawn and
could drop another in the future yeah
really not easy for Magnus I think he
knows that Rook B1 objectively he's
still doing well that position you
highlighted the queen probably better
than the uncoordinated black Rooks
especially because black king still a
Target but in balanc positions that's
where fuja does Thrive and the longer it
goes without kind of Landing that
knockout punch and failing to Checkmate
the black king the more nervous Magnus
is going to get we see it in terms of
his uh time usage here down under 3
minutes I'm still predicting Rook B1
Robert because there's no other obvious
moves that call out Knight to B4 maybe
the kind of backup plan if you don't see
anything better but wow C4 Dynamite on
the board it's a pawn sacrifice he's
doing it the Brute Force way there's
another path in for the white Rook
Robert I love that move because without
pawns you open file so if that black
queen took that pawn C4 Rook C1 would
have hurt now Knight to B4 that move
looks great I mean the C6 Fork we've
already been talking about it now hits
the royal family all of the pieces the
Royal Fork hitting them with check night
before exclamation point and that could
be the dagger that could be the final
touch black now needs to cover the C6
Square needs to hope that uh Magnus
jumps in at the wrong moment Rook to C8
strictly obliged I don't see anything
else at all otherwise you resign you get
forked and uh the game is up but 17
seconds for fer he does play that move
the problem is the white Bishop can move
rookie seven is coming Pawn to C5 will
blow open more lines White Queen can
move threatening Knight to C6 it feels
like something is crumbling uh look at
that poor black knight all of the Rhymes
we come up with that we talk about
really uh kind of applicable really
relevant right now blacks defending with
only a king and queen it's not going to
cut the mustard here Robert it looks
almost game over Knight on H6 a in the
mix and that's part of why black is in
trouble and here I like your see C5 move
a ton it doesn't give black the obvious
response it's trying to set up Knight C6
check with some deadly forks and trying
to remove the guard of the queen on A5
so Magnus Carlson he's sitting and
thinking Knight C6 check probably
winning for white but he doesn't
necessarily want to rush it because if
you start trading off too many pieces
maybe that gives black some faint hopes
of survival he goes for it the
evaluation bar David it really tanked
quite a lot here as black can scoop up
this A6 Pawn we have even material wow
wow it plummets Magnus he knows he was
winning well he knew he was winning but
he cashed in too soon and now Robert
this could be a turn around it could
really turn the black aorn's alive the
Black Knight off the rim off the H6
Square it's back in the mix and okay one
more move I was going to say if the
black king came across to B6 into C5
black would have been totally fine but
magnus's Pawn still rolling I think he's
just about evaluated this correctly he's
aided by the fact fua has no time s
seconds left the pawns are running Rook
to E6 looks so strong right now but
Magnus he didn't find the most incisive
way I think nerves are kicking in the
most accidents happen nearer the
Finishing Line and okay could we still
see this turn Knight to D4 Magnus now
how is he going to finish whoa Robert
sacrifice we reacted at the same time in
the same way giving up the Rook because
this pong would promote that was sick
stuff from Magnus Carlson because other
moves would have given black some
chances and mag he played the move the
blue arrow indicated perfect stuff from
him perfect play Magnus Carlson with a
winning end game now but still how to
push those pawns through you don't want
to get them blockaded on light squares
don't allow the black king to come over
first he Boots the Black Knight out of
the center and uh now how to keep
pushing I don't think black is
threatening to take the pawn on C5 there
will be a check with Rook to E8 but
Magnus ticks under the one minute Mark
King to F2 he's doing it the slow way
he's trying to be slow and sure about it
but now a cck Robert and White's going
to make a new Queen there was really no
stopping the win for Magnus Carlson Ala
plays a couple moves but you can tell
that look on his face he can't believe
what has happened but the game is done
Magnus Carlson wins the first game what
a comeback from the champ David he was
on the back foot he lost the Grand Final
but it's reset and he successfully has
hit the reset button yeah that's what
great Champions do all of us lose games
everyone is human but it's about
bouncing back standing up at the
critical moments and Magnus makes
himself the favorite yet again for the
first time today he looked in Supreme
control and alaza after a really
ambitious start to that game couldn't
back it up Falls to defeat Magnus Carson
up 1 to Zer in the Grand Final
reset it's a best of two so a draw in
the next game wins it for Magnus Carlson
and for Ali Raza fua it's the first time
all day he has had a deficit remember he
sprinted to a first two game lead
against Magnus winning both of them
before making that fourth game Draw to
secure his reset opportunity so David I
mean ala fua now suddenly it feels like
momentum has shifted away from him yeah
it's really gone wrong after that
blistering start the foundations are
crumbling but he needs to pull himself
together this is where he can shine he
has the white pieces he's done it before
forja he has taken down Magnus multiple
times with the white pieces throughout
his career he just needs to do it one
more time when it really matters I still
believe in him Robert I would love to
see an Armageddon game between these two
um it feels like it deserves to go the
distance but it's not going to be easy
Magnus is going to try play spoiler
she's going to try and lock this next
game
down well one person who does not want
to see Armageddon and maybe the only
person because all chess fans they want
free chess they want overtime is Magnus
Carlson he won game one he has his first
lead of the day he had two days off in
between his winers final and the grand
final today so for Magnus Carlson David
I feel like he has found his form at
just the right time if you're a fan of
his yeah magnus's fans will have been
jumping up and down that last game it
was so dramatic it might have been
slipping away he didn't find the
cleanest kill But ultimately Magnus he's
always getting the job done even when
he's not in top form um he just has this
extra gear this extra level and uh it's
about whether he can keep that up now as
we mentioned the closest you get to the
Finishing Line we saw it from fuia
earlier the more nervy you get fua has
to pounce on that he has to just forget
every single thing now just go on the
attack go for magnus's
throat and that is ala F style he wants
to go all out for the attack but it
backfired in game one where with the
black pieces he played a line that
castled on the opposite sides of the
board his attack it never appeared and
so Magnus Carlson was able to secure
that game one with some clever tactics
of his own now in game two at least ala
gets white he'll have to bring the fight
to his world number one rated opponent
yeah and uh for better or worse there's
minimal break time between these two
games so they're thrown right back into
the thick of the action fua needs to
recover at a moment's notice Magnus
feeling a lot more comfortable you can
see it on the camera he's uh back in the
zone and it's the Italian game Robert I
can confirm I did have some pasta for
dinner last night inspired by all of
those Italian we saw and uh wow what do
you make of this opening Choice bring
the bishop out early to G5 in a musn
situation I think it's a good call from
alza and a better call from Magnus not
pushing his G Pawn as is the case in
many italian games when your opponent
brings the dark score Bishop out with a
pin so instead Magnus he brought his
Bishop to C5 then back to E7 he wastes a
turn so to speak but it's to keep the
foundation of his position solid do not
give aliisa the type of aggressive play
that he so desperately
desires yeah Magnus just trying to lock
things down we mentioned he will try to
suck the life out of this position he
won't want to allow it to explode uh to
become fun but fua he has this uncanny
Knack of making positions exciting later
on making them really complicated
sometimes it backfires on him we've seen
that in that previous game but fuja if
he can somehow make it happen when
Magnus least expects it he does stand a
chance right now Rook to E1 feels like
fu is in preparation look at the clock
times Magnus pushes a pawn he's next
going to move the king out of the
eyeline of the white light Square bishop
and it might be on the king side here
Robert fuja needs to strike and soon in
the center as you said the Knight can
jump out to H5 to put some pressure on
this bishop on G3 so the idea is clear
now from Magnus and he was a bit lacking
in space in particular his Bishop on E7
that's staring into its own pieces so he
is trying to create new avenues for the
rest of his pieces I love the move G6
it's a very smart play now for aliisa do
you continue with natural development
Knight C3 maybe even Knight to D5 if the
black knight ever moves or do you save
your Bishop David with A Move Like H3
it's a bit calmer it's quieter but it
does keep the game going in a way that
Al Isa may want yeah I like paon H3
creating a nice uh Escape Square for
that Bishop on H2 also preventing one of
Black's main ideas if white breaks out
in the center I would love to play Pawn
to D4 open the middle of the board uh
control the middle of the board
potentially but Pawn to D4 here might
run into Bishop to G4 pinning and at
least causing some discomfort for white
so Point H3 a multi-purpose move you
call it Robert on the board now and uh
Magnus he might not have time to play on
the king side with his F Pawn he plays
Rook to E8 a bit inconsistent but he's
trying to get ready for the white D4
Pawn push which looks imminent might
even happen now on this next turn and
Bishop to f8 very passive viewers at
home might be wondering you know the
freestyle challenge the freestyle goat
challenge starts in a couple of days why
is he putting all his pieces back on the
back rank but Magnus just trying to get
organized he's trying to improve the
scope of his
rook and the bishop the bishop will come
to G7 where if D4 is played it will have
a longer diagonal to work with this was
the cost of Magnus Carlson's opening it
wasn't just time it was shutting the
door on activity for the dark Square
bishop and this bishop on C8 but we
typically tell you not to move the same
piece multiple times this dark Square
Bishop has moved three times the bishop
on8 hasn't moved at all eventually it
can go to a square like E6 but there's
no rush for it because uh that Bishop
it's future is not evident Bishop E6
doesn't want to sit there does it want
toh sit on D7 a little bit more quietly
these questions are not easy to answer
so Magnus punts on the decision for now
yeah and uh look at the clock time as
well already it's still early days both
players in preparation until recently
but fua just looks like the slower
player right now maybe in his own head a
bit too much thinking about the match
situation Bishop to H4 though Robert
that is the definition of provocation
he's uh trying to pin he's trying to
force Magnus to lash out with a move
like G5 but um that's never going to
happen Magnus is never going to open up
his King in a situation he just needs a
draw Bishop back on G7 now looks really
solid for black how to break this
formation it's not
easy I like the idea from Ali Rea as you
said he's trying to provoke G5 Magnus
wants no part of that he does not want
to push Pawns in front of his own King
he wants to ensure its safety so what
next that is a huge question in order uh
to start going for ideas and trying to
take advantage of squares he sometimes
need to move pawns create Pawn breaks
and open up files but a move like D4 is
now the right time now the black Bishop
is sitting on G7 it looks difficult to
accomplish and that's why we see the
Knight into D5 so David black is
responding Magnus all of his moves they
logical follow-ups to White's choices
yeah really logical moves from Magnus
just improving pieces but finally I
think he might have to answer the
question what next this last move Pawn
to C3 indicates that white has covered
pretty much every Square on his first
four ranks Queen to B3 was in the air
hitting on the queen side Magnus trades
off Robert and this is a really
committed decision Black's light Square
Bishop was one of the pride and joys of
his position covering all the light
squares we talk about the Italian
opening the Spanish opening white light
Square Bishop as well on his side the
pride and joy and now it's uncontested
this piece to my eyes this looks like a
favorable trade for white do you think
Magnus has something specific up uh kind
of in store for
us well he pushed his G Pawn it's not
something he wanted to do but it allowed
him to get that light squ Bishop back so
Black's Pawn structure on the queen side
is doubled isolated A5 Pawn that can be
a Target later on and you've pressed
forward on the king side but magnus's
claim David is that his King is safe and
sound because there are no white
attackers in front of it so is this Pawn
A5 a weakness I would say absolutely but
difficult to get to it takes a night
journey to reroute and get there I like
White's position I have to admit but I
think that Magnus he's not unhappy to be
here yeah Magnus has advantages of his
own including this really strong black
knight now sitting on F4 and uh will he
score that's the big question the Black
Knight now solidified and fuja
desperately trying to undermine it if
black now captures in the center Pawn
takes D4 I think alare here he would
leap on the opportunity of removing that
black knight from the board with his
Bishop forcing black to break the pawn
chain really ugly structure there so I
don't think Magnus is going to get Hasty
he want will want to keep the tension
instead but this one's building Robert
it feels like it's uh really starting to
come to life the real fireworks in the
near future but uh right now there's
enough imbalance there's enough hope for
fosa and uh yeah I'm liking what he's
doing he's at least got a position he's
got a game and he's alive in this
final and Black's Pawn structure is not
getting any better anytime soon in fact
if white takes on E5 and black takes
back we see double isolated C Pawns in
addition to the IED a pawn but Magnus he
is counting on activity and play against
the white king and ala he does have the
long-term advantages so David I would
say that as this game continues the
advantage is in Ali raz's favor just
because of the pawn structure but the
dynamic play is in magnus's favor yeah
Robert I'm going to ask you to do one of
your favorite things to move some pawns
uh to squares that Unfortunately they
cannot go to if a black pawn were on B6
instead of C6 uh if Black's Pawn on G6
instead of G5 then Black's structure
would be perfect so harmonious no
doubled pawns isolated pawns no weak
squares in your camp but now the F5
square is a huge Target for the White
Knight to get into later the black
queens side pawns uh just right for the
picking in any end game uh any end game
actually White's simply going to win you
can create a pass Pawn on demand on the
a file so Magnus he won't be able to
rely on his endgame trickery anytime
soon um definitely long-term Advantage
white and I like the fact FIA has sped
up in what is his second Champions chest
or final six minutes on the clock
against seven that's closer than it has
been for a while so um definitely
shaping up nicely what do you think
Robert I'm going to ask you now put you
on the spot will we see Armageddon
today it's funny because I was about to
ask you a question I was going to say
doesn't it feel like magnus's position
is more of Ali raz's alley Where Al's
position is more Magnus style so in
regards to the Armageddon I actually
think it's quite likely just because
Magnus only needing a draw may have to
play forcefully and that's not
comfortable when you want to play Sol to
try to get that half
Point yeah Magnus will not be feeling
comfortable in the situation I've known
Magnus a long time and he really
dislikes it when longterm he's suffering
when he has these ugly pawns and needs
to compensate by showing real uh kind of
energy and uh to kind of gamble in a way
and he is trying to gamble now Bishop to
C5 Robert given a question mark it drops
a pawn it's a big big sacrifice a
committal sacrifice Knight takes A5 is
available for white is greed good here
does fuja jump in and just call that
bluff and I guess he's got to be worried
about his King side but does Magnus have
anything concrete against the white king
I must confess I don't see it I don't
see any
justification surely if he wants to win
this match there we go he does get
greedy he snaps off the pawn and Magnus
goes in G for Glory Will he win this
game what do you make of this can white
fend off the
attack I think that Al is just in time
we talk about hooks that G4 push if
there was something attacked on F3 would
have pride open the white king side but
for now everything is under control H4
is a good move if black had a queen on
G6 already then G3 becomes a deadly
threat thanks to Bishop on C5 but that
seems quite a ways away and white will
see it coming Slide the king to the
corner and then maybe even move the
bishop out to uh G3 not now Bishop G3
would simply blender a piece but in the
future the move uh Bishop to G3 if the
king is on H1 seems to have White's
position looking safe and sound yeah
King to H1 one of the first moves you
mentioned then a bishop on G3 it looks
like an unassailable Fortress and uh one
that's actually cropped off in a lot of
classic games throughout chess history
um especially if white puts a bishop on
G3 and that Bishop's captured by the
Black Knight that pawn shelter that pawn
formation of Pawns on G2 G3 H4 just no
way through white king will live a
thousand years in the corner uh kind of
on the H2 Square so F I think he's doing
everything right I think Armageddon is a
big favorite in this one Magnus does
need some real magic uh in order to save
this game I don't see it white is simply
going to come back with the Knight to C4
start pushing the a pawn or the B Pawn
full control Queen G3 uh Queen F6 I was
going to say metant by Bishop G3
guarding everything and this Pawn
formation wow I must admit I missed this
one but Magnus allowing an end game
despite how bad the black pawns
are counterintuitive to trade Queens
when you're down material all of our
coaches taught us if you're trailing you
want more pieces on the board because
end games will not be favorable but
Magnus spots that the pawn structure May
collapse very quickly with a bishop on
F2 also hitting this Rook on E1 so very
clever attempt from Magnus and Al says
I'm not afraid let's go outside pass
pawns usually Rule the Day in the end
game he brings his Rook Behind the B
Pawn it gets a question mark I am
ridding us of that question that is a
good decision I think ala is fully in
charge yeah he is dominating this game
we said it earlier any endgame favors
white due to the power of the uh past
porn the white a porn is likely to win
this game and I'm going to call it Alara
the a pawn it's going to start sprinting
forward very very shortly Magnus though
what's he pausing about surely he has to
snap off the pawn on G3 before it
disappears before the white king steps
forward and defends it um he's a pawn
down after all the C6 Pawn is collapsing
look at those accuracy levels fuja
playing one of the games of his life so
important here and he's playing so well
Robert so strongly and Magnus okay
desperately trying to mix it pawn to F5
we see the evalar not approving not
liking this move but he's desperately
trying at least a source of play a
source of light at the end of the tunnel
for the black E Pawn is there a way to
stop it running that's the big
question looks difficult to stop if the
pawn captures on F5 which seems to be a
natural try there it goes the bishop on
F2 helps it out as you just rush the ewn
up the board with the Rook behind it for
good measure so Ali rer right now he
sees how dangerous the position is David
can he just grab this C6 Pawn with his
Knight and then work around what will be
an annoying e- Pawn passer that black
will try to turn into a queen I think he
can I think alza could get away with it
but that would as you mentioned allow
counterplay the move I would want to
play here if it works if it if you can
calculate is Rook to F1 just to try and
take the black F5 Pawn with your Rook
kill the counterplay before it even
begins kill it at source and uh if you
can somehow kick the black Bishop out
the way take that pawn you're just
loving life black has no passes black
can basically resign the only
complication is the fact that black
might be able to play a move like Bishop
to B6 hitting the White Knight you have
to work out that it all kind of falls
into place um I don't see any reason not
to though Robert Bishop B6 I think you
can just meet with Knight takes C6 in
that position we're spitting out some
variations but this is all that's going
through Fu's mind he does not want to
allow Magnus a glimmer of hope I'm
predicting Rook F1 I think that's what
he's trying to work out he does not by
Nature want to allow any activity oh wow
he just plays B4
instead wow and that move I actually
think deserves the question mark your
Rook F1 idea is well taken it would have
prevented black from getting this pass
pawn and F takes E4 certainly looks like
a nice try Bishop takes g3 at any moment
is going to potentially win the H4 Pawn
but David this position they don't have
the evaluation bar by their side they're
going on their own Magnus doesn't know
that he suddenly has an opportunity
because you play a move like Pawn takes
E4 I think that Al is just going to take
this Pawn C6 pushes B pushes a pawns and
those are hard to stop as well yeah
still super difficult for black um as
you say Robert correctly the eval bar is
not available for the players so they
know the momentum the trend of the game
it's all been about white Alara is the
one who's made things happen who's got
the long-term advantages Magnus is in
Hustle mode and uh there we go what a
move really classy move there from
Magnus Carson the white E Pawn is not
running away anytime soon Black's E5
Pawn is the one that he wants to push
down the board but it needs support from
the black Rooks and this black Rook that
he just moved was about to get kind of
semi- Trapped now it's going to Spring
Forward first gain time against the
White Knight which is defended and now
two pass pawns double pawns all over the
shot Robert who's are more
dangerous I would be thinking Rook to B4
just to go after these pawns on the
fourth rank but that E Pawn is the one
you need to stop and of course black
will push it forward and then again and
then one last time before it becomes a
queen so I would be super nervous here
if I were ala fuia the evaluation bar is
at zeros neither player knows that but I
would say more than anything it's become
a game with all three results on the
table it looked like one-sided traffic
now Aliva f is probably worried about
how he continues because the E3 E2 E1
push is so obvious yeah Magnus Carson
I'm going to eat my words I thought he
was almost out of it I thought he was
devoid of any active counterplay
whatsoever but Pawn to F5 that was just
pure genius uh just giving him practical
chances and suddenly you can see it on
the camera visibly fu is nervous he
realizes it's no longer within his grasp
necessarily he still needs to play
really well and uh just to fend off
Black's active play he's given the
opponent a clear cut plan and uh that is
the cardinal sin of Rapid chess 1 minute
30 against 4 minutes suddenly it's an
uphill struggle suddenly Armageddon it's
a distant dream Rook to B4 I love it
Robert he plays it alera he is going for
those black pawns those weak pawns and
uh he's going to at least be able to
stop from behind the 4Runner the black
E4 Pawn if it steps forward but uh where
does Magnus now see counterplay it feels
like it's just a totally irrational end
game really hard to
evaluate irrational is a good word not
maybe necessarily in life but for this
position because Rook takes G4 is check
White currently has six pawns black has
five it's actually hard to count them
because you see that they are all
scattered they're mostly isolated and
after Rook takes G4 black will be a pawn
down so I would take this Pawn on G4 and
then try to bring my Rook back to E4 to
freeze Black's Pawns before they run
forward this is looking like a position
where Magnus needs to prove that he can
hold the half point and whoa as soon as
I say that the wrong move from Ali Raza
and the blue arrow is in David Rook D2
and Magnus isn't just okay apparently
he's winning wow Alara missing the
opportunity to grab a pawn for free with
Czech I'm not so sure about that one he
maybe was afraid of taking that pawn and
allowing the black king closer towards
the center but of course Magnus jumps on
that opportunity he finds the move
indicated by the blue arrow exclamation
point E2 is coming followed by Rook to
D1 check and you're Landing you're
touching down that black porn is going
to become a new Queen it's coronation
day almost not just for the king Magnus
Carson but for that ewn allera he lost
control he allowed too much counterplay
and suddenly hard to even find a move
Robert it's inevitable you can't stop
Black's
plan and I wonder what the difference
was cuz turn to go it was all zeros and
Rook takes G4 that you could have stolen
a pawn I don't know why that would have
changed the nature of this position Rook
F1 played Black can in fact push the
pawn to E2 you'll get this Rook for a
bishop and pawn I wouldn't actually want
that just yet can black slow down David
can black be extra greedy protect this
bishop first and then push the pawn next
Magnus does it Magnus does it we saw
that look on magnus's face that kind of
momentary like that confusion that frown
why not why why aren't I just winning
right now and I think it's starting to
settle in it's starting to kind of
become real for both players they know
ala now down to 10 seconds nothing he
can do pawn to E2 wins a whole Rook this
might be the last few moves of the
Chester bable Masters 2024 Pawn to E2
looks automatic here Robert why not the
black Bishop's defended nothing to do
ala looked away 4 seconds left is this
the final moments of the
tournament it is Magnus Carl he needed a
draw but he gets a win and you can see
that he is relieved he's happy because
aliv of fuja gave him everything he
could handle winning the Grand Final
forcing the reset but when all is said
and done as is usually the case in top
level chess Magnus Carlson wins the
tournament the Chess World Masters 2024
the first event of the Champions chess
tour David what a performance from
Magnus his back against the wall after
losing the final he gets into the reset
and he was a new player yeah Magnus
revitalized and he struck back after a
disappointing start to the day in this
reset he brought his aame Magnus and fua
really didn't stand the chance it was
tough on the youngster fuja will be back
he will be better he will be surely in
More tour finals in future but
ultimately it is that man again Magnus
Carson he's the goodat for a reason
Robert he always seems to get the job
done and the Champions chest at the CCT
seems to be his favorite event right now
uh just really really impressive his run
his consistency in these
events and uh in the me consistency that
is what it is oh sorry David I was just
going to say you know serious
consistency and Brilliance from him and
this look bad but David take it away how
did he escape this and not just survive
but win yeah let's uh jump into the
games where Magnus did eventually win I
just wanted to point out one moment
after uh Rook to B1 if we fast forward a
bit later towards the end game it was
here I was indicating mistakenly that
black should take this Pawn After All
Black's a pawn down but Magnus this is
why he's the best this is why he's the
class above he realized the Urgent uh
situation here and he created
counterplay it looks really stuck for
black how are you ever going to create a
pass porn but F5 and we're live this one
simply winning uh the match I think
psychologically for Magnus the
evaluation bar still says good for white
but it was the turning point in this
game now if white takes this Pawn the
black pawn steps forward and there's a
straight path through to Glory through
to the promotion square instead allera
took a timeout Pawn to B4 and Rook to d8
activation over everything and uh as we
saw the final mistake was in this
position Rook to B4 alera should have
taken this Pawn with a check and only
then come back to E4 but unfortunately a
slip a Miss Rook to E4 and Magnus the
finishing position I'm going to put on
the screen Here pawn to E2 there's
simply nothing this Rook can do to stop
the promotion of this Pawn if the Rook
moves for example then Rook to D1 would
close the door with promotion and
checkmating ideas on the cards Magnus
magnificent Magnus wins
again it seems like it is inevitable
when Magnus Carlson plays but what a
turnaround in that game the queen side
was dropping he goes after the king side
and D what a brilliant way to exchange
the Queens to get into an end game where
he saw that epon could run fast that's
just amazing recognition from the world
number one yeah he seems to be two three
steps ahead of his opponent sometimes
Magnus two or three steps ahead of us
for sure that was really unexpected it
looked really difficult for black but
turning things around and yeah critical
moments that's when the top players
really shine um yeah commiserations to
Ala I can't stress it enough really put
on a great fight today but ultimately
it's that man again if you come for the
king you best not miss and you all in
the audience you better not miss this
interview with Magnus Carlson once again
winning an event in the Champions chess
stour starting the season off right so
leave your questions in chat we may
feature a couple of them but we're going
to head out and win return we'll be on
the call with Magnus Carlson your 2024
ches Masters
[Music]
winner
welcome to to a world where each game
writes a new story with endless
possibilities and surprising twists we
present the next big new tournament the
freestyle chess goat challenge at the
Forefront of this epic chess spectacle
is none other than Magnus Carlson the
former world champion facing his first
duel with the reigning world champion
ding Len since his title victory in
addition to this top duel Carlson has
selected six other top Challengers to
make the tournament especially
exciting be sure to watch all the games
on the live stream at chess.com and on
our freestyle-house-music-genre
[Music]
so
is
[Music]
n
oh
[Music]
people can beat Magnus Carlson once and
it's very rare to see someone beat him
twice how did you do that in the first
first match and how are you feeling
about how it
went yeah of course um good I started
with two
wins um of course the first game was he
could have made Perpetual check but
uh he went for risk option and I felt my
king on H6 was pretty safe so after that
I had um good result but
um
the first match doesn't count
so how the format
is yeah I mean there is the reset and
the second one didn't go your way but
does it build confidence in you that you
can beat Magnus a couple times in a row
especially as you head to the candidates
later this
year not really it doesn't change so
much we have
to um for sure not for
well Al R it you're a fighter and we saw
that fighting Spirit from you today I
mean coming into today the odds were not
in your favor are you proud at all of
yourself like are you feeling like you
did just show some excellent chest that
you can be proud of looking back on
it I was I'm very disappointed with the
second match but I was really tired
because to
make uh to always you have to win and um
the second match the first match took a
lot of energy so um it's a big advantage
of course for the person that goes with
the wi in the winner bracket but yeah it
was
a I think it was I played good but the
result was not the way I
wanted do you think at some point you
know you'll look back a little bit I
know it's it's fresh so it hurts you're
such a competitor uh but you know what
you were able to do today I think that
was impressive to so many fans out there
who are rooting you on so do you think
you know a few days you'll look back a
little bit differently on this event and
maybe have a little bit of reason to
smile I mean I'm happy that I got at
least to the final Grand Final event so
um it's not easy to get out of the
playing even so I'm happy that I'm here
but yeah today could have been the I'm
very disappointed with the second match
of the first game so uh I couldn't
do the attack work and I couldn't
coordinate my pieces so but beside that
I'm pretty
happy yeah you did lose the first match
overall to Vladimir FV and I mean you
went through a who's who of the Chess
World so I mean you were living on one
life until the very last match so I feel
like yeah you did prove that you are
resilient as all hack so I I do think
you should be uh quite proud of yourself
ala thank you
and uh we did want to just feature a
couple chat questions so um you know we
have one from aditia
x26 asking how do you prepare for events
like these do you prepare any specific
lines or are you relying more on
Instinct um the whole day I was fighting
with trying be the organizer to in
Germany to make the internet work so the
fact that I had internet today was
good enough for
me so it seems like playing away from
your usual setup was a bit of a struggle
but and ala I know you have another
tournament coming up I I can of course
sense the disappointment I just want to
reiterate you do have a ton to be proud
of so I don't want to keep you on for
the call but there's so many fans out
there who have celebrated your success
do you have anything to say to all the
new fans in chess especially your
growing fan
base
keep watching the game and keep
supporting me I
guess well Al there Isa I think they
will you did just have tremendous
fighting Spirit we will let you go uh it
was a tough defeat but congratulations
on second place and you'll be back in
division one in the next Champions chest
T our event so uh get some rest I know
you have a new event coming up but thank
you so much for stopping by even after
the disappointment all is
it thank you and we will be back shortly
with interview with your Champion Magnus
Carlson stay tuned everybody and ask
your questions for him we'll be back in
just a
[Music]
few
which one's
you the pawn I like the
pawn the Knight the Knight can jump over
pieces oh you want me to say the Queen
the Queen's the strongest piece on the
board this one's
you King The King sucks you can only
move one square you've got to reassess
your
chess Grandmaster morice Ashley presents
Jeremy Silman how to reassess your chess
now on chessable so go to chess.com
chess and start reassessing your chess
today
[Music]
n
ahahahahahahahah
[Music]
oh
welcome back everyone we are joined by
the winner of the 2024 Chester B Masters
Magnus Carson congrats Magnus and uh I
just wanted to ask what do you feel was
more wild today the chess or your
hair uh probably the chess but uh I
think the hair probably just got worse
as the games went
along what are your initial uh feelings
after that roller coaster over
match yeah I
think it was pretty similar to all the
matches that I I felt like I was
just um you know guessing trying to play
by intuition missing tactics left right
and center and uh you know just trying
to get through
and I was really I really needed my
extra life today that's for sure
um cuz
um uh I mean you could see it in the in
the score as well but um also
psychologically it was kind of in that
sense it was kind of pleasant to go to
two nail down because then I knew I'd
like very certainly need uh the reset
anyway so
um so I I I didn't go into the reset
like particularly disappointed or
anything I was like okay yeah
um let's play two good games or let's
try U because he was also showing nerves
at that point so at that point I was not
too worried but yeah fa much
yeah were you impressed with how quickly
he came out of the gates how uh how well
he played at the beginning of the match
Al
Rosa yeah I thought the first game was
uh was a lot of fun and probably pretty
good uh as
well um yeah then I I I made this one
like overe eager move um Queen A5 there
playing for a win um more than anything
else I should know know
that uh if I get into these positions
againsta like usually will trick me and
I will lose uh so I was thinking that
during the game like why why am I
looking for a win but I couldn't really
couldn't really help it I could feel
that I was missing something several
times um but um but yeah I mean also in
the second game he out play me
completely um but um yeah it was uh was
was good to see him playing playing so
well um but he like everybody else I
don't know if he lost energy if got
nervous but it's hard to keep it
up and uh we were surprised uh I know
the chat was surprised as well by how
quickly you gave up on game four in set
one was that just to I mean what was the
thinking behind uh behind that
decision I just uh missed Bishop E2 and
I was kind of pissed about that and
there were no winning chances so I
thought
uh it's it's fine uh I I get white the
next game I start a new
um I yeah I know like technically you
give up a little bit of equity but I was
just like mentally done after after
missing that
move no fair enough uh I think it's
really refreshing to hear kind of the
honest thought process uh for uh the top
players and uh Magnus how's it feel
after winning so many different
Champions chess tour events you've won a
couple years in a row now and starting
the first event on a high as
well yeah it feels PR good um I've had
other matches here but I've been kind of
annoyed after after I won because I
didn't feel like I was playing great but
I think today I persevered through some
very difficult moments against a more
than worthy opponents um I'm very very
happy uh and uh
um yeah it was not a sparkling event for
me by any means but it feels feels
awesome to to
win and uh Magnus as usual we have some
questions from our chat uh so plastic
wrap asks first of all who do you think
is going to win the candidates is your
uh opinion altered a bit after today's
performance by
Ala yeah not necessarily um
so this tournament that I'm playing now
in in Germany um it's really a class of
generations cuz there are four young
guys and there are four old guys and
here I think it's very very open um well
I'm obviously one of the old guys if
anybody was um was wondering um and here
I think it's very very open while in the
candidates I
do think that the old guys still have
have a bit of an edge um so that would
be my guess one of
the uh one of the old guys when oh
Magnus I'm two weeks older than you you
can't use the word old 33 is the new 18
we're
fine um I mean speaking of this event
you mentioned you're in Germany now uh
we have a question from Krishna
21234 and uh the question is asking how
excited are you for the 960 freestyle
event
is there anything specific you're doing
uh to prepare for
it I um I'm very excited for the event
I've tried to play some training games
um but that didn't go so well uh so I
kind of give up on on that but I've been
I've been studying
[Music]
some um different different opening uh
strategies and sort of
um I think like initial strategy except
for playing training is all you can
study uh really so even though there's
not there is in theory I've been trying
to get more of a feel of where the
pieces Go in different situations but
it's super difficult and challenging so
I'm really looking forward to it you
mentioned those training games didn't go
too well Magnus your opponent must have
been super strong yeah must have been uh
somebody who's uh
not
old okay Magnus um that just leaves us
to say congratulations Champions chess
tour first event of season 2024 in the
books you won it again uh yeah you must
be thrilled and best of luck in Germany
we'll be watching thank you thank you so
much okay cheers
Magnus that was Magnus Carlson your 2024
Chess Masters champion he wins the first
leg of the Champions chess tour there
are only four legs this year he also
stamps his ticket to the season and
finals David we heard him with in his
interview with you just now he seems
quite happy yeah he seems in good
spirits Magnus Carlson and we know that
happy chess players play the best and uh
yeah he was a bit relieved I feel mixed
in there uh the emotion or roller
coaster Robert it was up and down today
but ultimately he got the job done and
uh he's going to be one to watch at this
uh freestyle tournament next week yeah
just really great to see him in top
spirits but uh also when you chatted
with fuja I'm cheering for him I think
uh the way he played today in the
candidates in the 960 tournament he's
earned so many more new fans and he's
going to be back and stronger and I
think everyone understands the mindset
that fio was in a disappointing finish
he beat Magnus Carlson in their grand
final match and in the reset he just
couldn't get his feet Underneath Him He
struggled in game one and lost he heard
it from Ala himself he was very
disappointed in that and then game two
he did have an advantage for a few turns
but it was a tricky position and he
ended up going down to defeat so when
all of said and done Magnus Carlson he
ends up in first place he also wins a
cool
$30,000 so let's revisit our cheser
Master standings presented by wealth
management partner Julius bear Magnus
Carlson $30,000 plus those tour points
If we're honest the tour points for
Magnus they're irrelevant because he has
just earned his spot in the season and
finals but for everybody else on this
list those tour points and those dollar
bills they are going to be gladly
swooped up stored and used later and
hopefully for some of them by season end
they'll accumulate enough tour points to
qualify for the finals by that method
yeah every Point matters uh on the chess
board every move matters as well this is
the Champions chess tour and it's such a
long season uh Robert it's just been a
fantastic start the whole chest B
masters from the playin stage across all
the divisions and ultimately Magnus
today we're becoming used to that but uh
yeah it's shaping up really nicely for
2024 it is and it's not just about the
top division yesterday we saw the
division 2 and division three finales
where Vincent kimer he won in division
two we'll see him in division one the
next time and then for Alexi s he gets
to skip the play in he'll be in division
placement along with some of the others
but as we look at our tour standings
presented once again by our wealth
management partner Julius bear we see
that the top four names are the same
players who finish in the top four spots
of division one but in fifth place David
we see Vincent kimer and then we're
going to see other players who were
participating in the division 2 and
division 3 tournaments because they
actually were able to secure quite a
number of tour points themselves yeah in
the Champions chess tour we reward
perseverance we uh reward the stamina
the players uh especially division 2 and
three these kind of giant divisions
they're battling in out fighting for
their lives playing game after game and
really nice to see professional players
being supported like this given
opportunities and watch out for some of
those other names lower down the
divisions to come back challenge the
likes of Magnus Carlson next time it's
such an open field it's nice to see so
many worldclass Grand Masters take part
and uh it just adds to the excitement
for sure the Intrigue the excitement
it's always through the roof in the
champion chest because are three super
strong divisions we are going to have a
second event a few months from now and
we do have three confirmed players
Magnus Carlson as the winner of the ches
Masters Ali Raza fua his runner up and
then vitet kimer for winning that super
strong division 2 me in the end he
outlasted leavon aronian but before that
there were some huge names and confirmed
players in for division placement they
get a head start they may work their way
into the top division Dennis lvic yand
palomi from their performance is in
division one then Levon Ron in division
2 second place and Alexa Sera he wins
division three at minimum he will move
up to division two but David I don't
think we'll be surprised if he is in the
top division in the next event yeah Alex
say s super impressive yesterday when we
followed him uh seizing that division 3
title and um yeah everything all games
so much on the line and uh yeah just
really nice to see it feels like the
perfect start to the season all of uh
these top players bring their aame
showing how much they want it Robert and
they'll have to bring their aame to all
of these tournaments just because this
one has come to its conclusion does it
mean that you get to stop watching chess
yeah I'm not forcing you to watch but
look at this calendar how are you going
to miss out on this we start with the
freestyle chess go challenge that begins
in just a couple days from now then
we'll have our Champions chess League I
think that's the Collegiate chess league
on Saturdays and we have the FED candid
tournament that determines who gets the
face off against dingi Ren for the world
championship title and then we have our
second CCT event May 8th to 15th so
Circle that on your calendar maybe
quickly take a screenshot if you're
technologically savvy I sometimes
struggle with that and then Mark it down
and come join us watch these shows David
what an event we just had in the chess
bu Masters Magnus Carlson winning first
place that's not particularly surprising
I will say however he was given tough
fights from FV lazik fuja do you feel
like the field is getting tighter as
players they are maybe not as fearful of
Magnus Carlson as they once were
definitely fully agree Robert the Young
Generation they're coming we saw it
today this generational Clash Magnus is
dropping in that o word old he's
mentioning it he's saying that the
challenge is getting tougher every
single time and uh it definitely feels
like uh the heat is coming for these
more established players today's Final
wasn't decided until the very final
minutes that's how close things are
becoming that's how open it's becoming
and uh as Magnus said in the interview
in the interview so much to look forward
to starting with the freestyle goat
challenge but the candidates on the
horizon more Champions chest tour events
what a year it's going to be and there's
just so much more access to these top
players in particular to world number
ones and world champions because back in
the day fiser and spasy they had barely
played against each other before uh s
sitting down for the world championship
match and that was the epic showdown of
these Rivals who weren't too familiar
with one another but now that players
get to face off against Magnus Carlson
more and more in all sorts of time
controls it also means that he will lose
more games just because there's a higher
quantity but he still in the end shows
that quality is there Magnus Carlson the
number one rated player so David I just
don't know how to wrap up this event
because there were so many story lines
across the three divisions yeah so many
story lines it's Essen EV the old guards
trying to cling on to their spots at the
top of well chest the elite that's been
established for so long but the
youngsters coming I think inspiring
hopefully for everyone at home watching
this as well to play online chess to
play speed chess to hone those skills we
saw what it takes today you need to be
tricky you need to be alert you need to
be inside your opponent's head you need
to be unflappable and um yeah this uh
this kind of era of online chess is only
getting more exciting um these hybrid
tournaments as well Robert it's it's a
good time to be life it's a great time
to be a chess
player well we saw upsets we saw
brilliancies we saw Jubilation for some
players and disappointment for others so
David as we wrap up the Chess Masters
any final thoughts Before We Say
Goodbye uh just that it's been a
pleasure commentating alongside you
Robert uh as always it's been a lot of
fun I hope everyone at home's enjoyed it
I hope it's inspired everyone to log on
tonight play a few sneaky games on
chess.com but yeah it's just been a
pleasure it's always a pleasure covering
the action with you and of course with
Tanya satv we started in the plays with
Danny wrench and d nitzki and thank you
to everybody who's stuck around you've
been here since the start there were
some triumphs some fist bumps some
sadness and disappointment but in the
end the Chess Masters was a fantastic
event it's the first leg of four in the
Champions chest St you'll not want to
miss the next event May 8th to 15th but
for now we say goodbye on behalf of
David Howell and myself and all those
chess.com we'll see you next time in
Champions chest
[Music]
finish that was sick from Aller I see
progress with a helping hand but
unfortunately again you're playing
Magnus Carlson and he is a Marathon Man
whoa Magnus Carson lost her time are you
kidding me Queen G6 would be check me he
walked into a meeting then oh my gosh
and Vladimir F have so claw unbelievable
armagon Magnus cursing his luck here he
knows Dennis has done perfectly and he's
about to lose with white Magnus this
nearly never happens the pawn drops
Dennis takes a historic Victory Yan he's
just checking he's just hoping now but
36 37 seconds alaz is forcing the Queens
off otherwise it's Checkmate is this the
end of Yan's tournament it is the end of
the road for Yan I think he's just in
time here fua to hold the draw he has
this under control it is fua who
progresses but d through everything at
this game he got so close Magnus is
blundered oh and Magnus missed a simple
quiet pawn move though black king is
safe is completely winning for fuia now
David this is getting out of control for
Magnus Carlson Knight C3 a winning move
Robert double attack he is just
dominating Magnus Carlson wow a lot of
fans will be pleased a lot of fans will
be devastated it's the London system B7
comes and then Rook C8 shuts down the
axis of the black Rook along the eighth
R and the bond promotes Magnus Carlson
he wins on time but he was winning on
the board has Magnus slipped up though
Bishop to E2 yes look at his face and
wow Magnus agreed to draw so he agreed
to lose the match there was really no
stopping the win for Magnus Carlson Ala
plays a couple moves but you can tell
that look on his face he can't believe
what has happened but the game is done
what a comeback from the champ he lost
the Grand Final but it's reset and he
successfully has hit the reset button
Magnus needs to prove that he can hold
the half point and whoa the wrong move
from Ali Raza Magnus Carlson wins the
tournament the Chess World Masters 2024
the first event of the Champions chess
[Music]
sword
oh
[Music]
he
n
[Music]
he